this is jocko podcast number 271 with
echo charles
and me jocko willing good evening echo
good evening
first they put us in a school in
tallafar and held us for 20 days
they didn't let us eat or drink only the
children were given a little bread
but we had to go to the bathroom to
share it
if they caught us sharing we were
tortured
the children were dying starving
they wouldn't drink the little amount of
dirty water
so we found some toothpaste and put it
in the water to pretend it was milk
so they would drink it and not die from
dehydration
dulled of emotion basima recalled
everything down to the most minor detail
how they were transferred to mosul in
cattle trucks
and stashed in a traditional ceremony
hall
how the elderly had to give their
children urine to drink
to keep them alive after isis cut their
only water pipe
how everyone became so sick and
malnourished
that clumps of their hair would fall to
the floor
but the worst was yet to come
in the middle of the night the isis men
were coming in and yelling to know
who was still a virgin bessema whispered
and from the age of eight they were
taking girls to the market to sell
for a cigarette
however bessema and several of her
siblings
fought up a plan to avoid being violated
they tried to
look like ugly boys by using a piece of
broken plate to shave their heads
and dressed in the men's clothes they
found hidden away
we thought if they mistook us for boys
we would be taken out and killed
rather than raped she explained
but instead when they knew our trick the
men came in and stripped us in front of
everybody
in front of everybody hundreds
they touched us everywhere sexually
abused us
my father and brother had to watch
and that was the last i saw of them
basima did not shudder when she talked
about the abuse
she was telling her story but she was
also telling
somebody else's story she was telling
the story of so many other women
perhaps that is how she was able to get
through it with strength
by separating herself from the narrative
when initially snatched gazal
was with her six-month-old son
bhaktiarar and five-year-old daughter
darren when gazal
while gazal clutched her screaming son
basima claimed to be the mother of
darren in hopes that
the isis operatives wouldn't sell her if
it was clear she was no longer a virgin
gazal spoke of her ordeal in a tempered
rhythm
relentlessly tugging at her dress and
glaring at her raw
cracked hands
at first she said she refused to go with
the wali
but he dragged her by her hair and took
her to
her and baktiyar to the syrian city
of minbij near the turkish border
they were yanked into a house like the
headquarters
where there were already two other
yazidi slaves
and a constant ebb of foreign fighters
the wali said i must marry him
but i refused so he took my son and i
didn't see him for two days
after that i begged and cried
he started torturing me and said i had
no option but to marry him
only it wasn't a real marriage
there was no ceremony
it was just rape
i was forced to be a muslim
to pray five times a day
the coalition bombs soon started falling
on isis
installations bases and homes but they
also fell on people who were already
scared and suffering
who had no arms and no choice but to be
there
after gazal was gone besima said that
she and scores of others
including young darren were wounded in
an airstrike on the prison
shrapnel pierced her head besima's only
treatment
was her long ebony locks getting shaved
off
she received no medicine
the slaves were propelled down 22 skewed
steps
into an underground weapon storage
filled with guns and bombs
which would become their living quarters
for more than a year
we were tortured
there were no toilets we had to eat
sleep
and do the necessary all in the same
place
all kinds of insects and flies were in
there
they forced us to convert to islam
we were made to look at beheaded bodies
through the little window
we didn't know when our time was up
all we could think about was whether it
was better to live
or to die
what is a war
it is trying to remember those we
treasure who are taken
while at the same time trying to let
them go
what is war it is waiting to kill or is
waiting to be killed
what is war war is a war inside the war
which the world cannot see
but sometimes if you get close enough
you can hear it
it is inmates being endlessly beaten
lashed
maimed with sadistic tools and kept in
small cages
what is war a human shell
might have made it through the storm in
one piece but what is inside will
forever be filled with a dull
pain of waiting waiting for evil to
enter
to violate the person they once were one
more time
what is war it is ugly
it is lies it is ugly
lies what is war war is distrust
dishonesty skepticism
what is war war is a vision of agony
that becomes
normal that's what war does to people
what is war
everything you could imagine hell to be
only worse
and those are some excerpts from a book
called only
cry for the living
which as you can see is a harrowing book
about the absolutely savage reign of
terror perpetrated by isis
in iraq and syria and throughout the
book and asked that question
over and over again what is war
and that is a complex question
and it requires answers from many
different angles
and this book does an incredible job of
giving us some of those answers
the book was written by an
australian-american journalist
by the name of holly mckay who
spent time on the ground in iraq
in afghanistan and syria has been
embedded with
australian and american troops sat
through military tribunals
and interviewed hundreds of soldiers
civilians and government officials
before during and
after the horrors of war
and it is an honor tonight to have
holly here with us to share
some of her experiences and some of the
things that she learned
along the way holly
thank you so much for coming down to
join us thank you for having me
this um is definitely a very
rough subject that you dove into and
that you pursued
and you know i i didn't know
you or anything about you really until i
started reading through the book i just
basically knew that you were a
journalist
but there's some interesting the pathway
that you took to get here as i kind of
explored that
is interesting and before we jump into
the book
i just want to kind of get some of your
background
you know it's going to say in most books
and it's true in most books people at
least
people write books and they say they're
not about themselves but they write
about themselves right and you actually
don't spend a lot of time writing about
yourself from this book
so just a little background before we
jump in
about you know so so you were born in
australia yes so i was born in north
queensland in australia and my dad was
in the mines so we moved around a fair
bit
um and then when i was very young i
became very
very heavily involved in in ballet and
so when i was 15
i went to a boarding school it was kind
of a fame school
in sydney where we could train full-time
uh
in different sort of arts and then we
did our sort of schooling
on the side as as well with that and we
could all work professionally and so it
was
it was just a very interesting way to to
study and grow up and i really thought
that
that was the career that i was going to
go into what was it was going to be
ballet dance it was going to be ballet
that is a psycho totally totally psycho
totally psycho and i you know but what i
i always say and people think it's just
it was the best training ground for what
i ended up doing
because you you learn to just
to push yourself beyond any kind of
boundary that you ever think and that's
just normal and when you're that young
you just
it's normal to be 15 hours a day in
these crazy shoes with bloody
feet and being yelled at and being told
you know you can only eat this this and
this and you have to weigh this and it's
just there's so much discipline
involved in it and it really was the
most amazing training ground but on top
of that
what it did was it really taught me so
much about the world that i wouldn't
have known in my
australian bubble when you say what you
just realized that through ballet there
was all these different
yeah we were other countries you know
yeah like
for me growing up a little new england
it's like okay
cool this is the world yeah and it's you
know i learned about the civil rights
movement through alvin ailey
who was this incredible um he's got an
art center in
in new york city and and that's how he
had this amazing piece called
revelations and i just remember being
about
16 and just watching it and just the
music and it was gospel music and i
learned about this sort of whole
culture and we did that with so many
parts of it i think
the rolling stones there was this
amazing ballet with that that
a canadian company had set to the
rolling stones and so i learned about
hedonism and all these you know
different things and errors that i
really didn't know and it really sparked
this
insatiable appetite for the world and
that was through the music
and this sort of deeper layer beyond
that and i really
that was what i wanted to pursue and
that's sort of why i i guess i left i
left home very young to go and study
i broke my ankle so that sort of set
back
some of the immediate professional
ideals that i had and so
as soon as i kind of healed a bit gone
to university
an opportunity came up to go to new york
to i had i got a scholarship i could
finish my degree there
and so i thought you know i'll finish a
degree maybe i'll go back into the arts
it didn't work out that way i ended up
in a journalism career and it was not
planned at all
um but yeah when you went to new york
did you go to study dance still no
so i was studying at a small university
just off wall street called pace that
was affiliated with my university in
sydney
and i was studying it was media arts but
i had a specialty kind of in writing was
what i
loved and i i wasn't sure what direction
i was going to take that or whether i
was going to go
back into the ballet field so
being in new york city i got a chance to
do both you know sort of the hub of
of creativity really and uh and kind of
study and have a really great time i
turned 21 in new york
then then so did you grow what did you
end up getting your
degree in media arts and production
which is a specialization uh
you know it's it's a it's a fancy ba but
it's i specialized in
in sort of writing and human rights
issues so i always had that sort of
passion of trying to understand the
world
in a little bit of a deeper lens i guess
at that point
so what year did you graduate from
college 2003
and then did you go back to australia so
no so when i was
in new york and i i arrived and then
everybody is talking about these
internships and i had no idea what it
was
in australia we just work you know you
work you go to school you
whatever um so they're talking about
internships i want to do one of those
things what are they this sounds
fascinating and i
i went to a bunch of of websites and i
stumbled across a fox website and i
didn't i didn't even know what fox news
was at that time
and it was early digital error and
i taught myself to web code just for fun
one
at school and so they said well we're
building up a digital
thing you know you obviously seem to
like that kind of thing would you like
to do that
so i thought yeah i'll give this a go
this sounds great and so i joined the
newsroom there and i really i fell in
love with
storytelling in a different way i was so
used to doing it
through dance through through physically
through my body
through other and and being able to kind
of be there and it was
much more literal than what i'd used to
but i really i fell in love with it and
being able to write and this whole new
medium was just
beginning and i just i really threw
myself into it and i loved it and then
at the end of it you know as i said i
was 21 and they said we'll sponsor you
if you'd like to come and
and work here full-time and so that sort
of made up my mind
pretty quickly that was a pretty amazing
opportunity
and uh the dance career might might have
to be for another life
um so yeah so i i was sponsored
and they said would you like to go to la
and i was i was really in love with new
york but i said sure let's go to la and
let's do this and so
i went to la and i guess by default
being in los angeles
uh there was you know the entertainment
hub of
the world and so that sort of seemed to
be and i had my own column
which again was sort of a bit of a
baptism by fire
and was just immediately thrown into
this
cage of of yeah i describe it when i got
there doco
it was the summer of 2007 and paris
hilton had just gotten out of jail
and somehow i'd made friends with an
assistant of hers and she was living in
this beach
house down in malibu and so every day
we'd go to these parties at paris's
and it was the paparazzis were lining up
on the beach and i just remember
thinking this is the biggest circus i've
ever seen
like this is this is ridiculous
and and and it stayed that way for me
and i think even though
i had some really incredible
opportunities and and
to to meet really amazing people too and
i don't think i really
at the time you know when you get to sit
down for 20 minutes with steven
spielberg or something i don't think i
really
you know valued i think i just i i was
too young to kind of understand this is
pretty cool
but i just got to meet so many people
from different walks of life i would be
i'd be covering a suge night trial in
compton and then the next minute i'd be
you know driving to to a choreography
session with the spice girls reunion
tour it was just this real
crazy you know be at at you know diddy's
party and then i would be at you know
some other cool place and
it but to me the funny thing about it
was i always felt
i was the outside looking in at
something i never felt part of it
i just felt like this was this
it was a launch pad but it was this
incredible stepping stone
and i guess similar to the ballet it
told me something really crucial which
was
to snuff out the bs and that's something
that's
i don't think there's a better training
ground for that than than being in that
entertainment world
because you learn to see through people
so quickly
and you learn to really navigate there's
so many layers around these people they
have
publicist managers there's just so many
layers
and a lot of intimidation people trying
to stop you from running a story people
trying to spin this this way that way
and it really taught me from a very
young age to be very resilient against
that
to be no that's not that's not what i
saw that's not what happened that's not
what the situation is
why are you doing that and i think yeah
i can't imagine
and that's something that's really
served me served me really well
so the the name of this what was the
name of your column
pop-tarts it was my old boss i don't
know where that came from
he just came up with it one day and said
this is what it's going to be and
let's do it did you isn't it
as a reporter aren't you supposed to
feel like an outsider
are you supposed to be on the outside
looking in and technically yes but in
the entertainment industry and this is
one thing that always bothered me about
it was that
people were so busy trying to be friends
with these people
and i could never get my head around it
i was like they're not my friend
i don't want to be their friend i have
my own friends and so i think people
always
automatically assume that you must yeah
that you must
you know want to be this friend and
everyone's kissing each other's ass on a
red carpet don't you look great tonight
no so people get totally sucked into the
whole totally sucked in
yeah and that was what yeah that was one
thing that annoyed mary
i i remember being about 22 in one of
those big entertainment shows
a producer had approached me and said
you know we'd love to talk to you about
a job and this and that and probably
stupidly because the money was probably
quite good but i said
oh no not interested thank you and that
was
my immediate reaction was i would just
have to sit there and
basically be nice to you all the time
and that wasn't
that wasn't the person i was i wanted to
understand
the real story behind it and
it's hard to do that in in hollywood
without sort of being
being shunned i guess and anyone who
does kind of do that
they are shunned they don't get the
access they want to the places and
things
and i think people are really drawn to
that world because
they want to feel that that being part
of something
so at what point did you sort of
envision
where what you really wanted to do so
i it was a slow process i started to do
a lot more
sort of investigative work and then i
would sort of pick up different
politics stories um i was always very
vested in world affairs and and there
was a great
a foreign correspondent in our bureau
and he'd spent a lot of time living in
pakistan and
and just you know had incredible stories
and he really and i sat with him and he
really
gave me that encouragement that i needed
and that was just you just have to go
and do it
you know you love to travel you've
traveled to all these places and i and i
traveled a lot and i'd sort of learned
to speak a little bit of arabic it's
gone now but
growing up i'd learned to speak and i
just had a real appetite for
understanding
different parts of the world and and
kind of growing up
growing up in the time when afghanistan
and iraq and a lot of
friends of mine that were my age were
kind of
being deployed and so i always really
wanted to understand it
and then with his name was dominique and
his support was
was just you've just got to go and do it
and so i
just i really just had to put myself out
there i had to be that annoying person
to my bosses
i want to do this i want to do this i
want to do this and luckily
i had people in in new york that
supported me that
looked at my work and thought well we've
thrown her on so many different stories
and she's always managed to come back
with something
and she knows how to investigate she
knows how to work independently so why
not
so that was sort of my my segue into it
and i really reached a point where i
knew i had to leave that entertainment
thing and
did you create enemies in the
entertainment thing
i wouldn't say i created enemies i mean
there were certain
you know i definitely had a few run-ins
and i definitely spoke my mind
probably more than it seems like if you
had the attitude like hey i'm gonna tell
the truth and people are trying to
adjust your stories and you're like not
not complying with what they want you to
do it seems like
it'd be a pretty easy environment to
make people mad
yes yeah it did it did and then to sort
of i guess toward the last
year or six months i was doing it i i
i probably looking back and it had
checked out a little bit
but yeah you do you create enemies as
you go and
again i just i think i just slowly was
removing myself at that point
anyway so what was the first did you get
like an
assignment just like your first
assignment that started to move you down
this path of this
going to war so i i was
uh i was in and i sort of been traveling
through the area and then i ended up
doing some work there uh was i guess the
the biggest one was i was in um the
middle east during when
2014 the war broke out in gaza so
i was sort of going back and forth
between
israel and and gaza and sort of being
able to cover it
because i was there that was kind of my
baptism by far what were you doing there
i i was there i was i was vacationing
visiting friends in jordan
i was hanging out with bedrooms in a
bedroom tent and you just saw a notebook
and a piece
a pen and a notebook and then you have
contacts back
in your news station and you say here's
what's going on just wrote this
and i i wrote some stuff there and then
i sort of went back and i thought this
was just and at that time that was also
when
isis had sort of really sparked i guess
in uh in in the middle east and i'd been
covering or closely sort of following
the arab spring which was all
in those years prior to that so i just i
was so
vested in it i guess and i i harassed
and harassed and then
made contacts with with different people
and fixes on the ground in iraq
and yeah i went for
to cover isis i guess after that would
have been the fall of 2014.
so that was in the very beginning stages
it's i mean i'm just sitting here
thinking
we everybody kind of knew what isis was
it's a very courageous move to say
that's what i'm gonna go
do go find out what these folks are up
to yeah and i use the term folks very
loosely with them
you know i'm gonna and and
um as i read through the book which i'm
going to
i'm not gonna do it justice because you
know we're only gonna obviously not
gonna read the whole thing right now
the the book is you know i got the
manuscript
i don't know when a year ago six months
ago
a year ago something like that uh
because we ended up publishing it
at jocko publishing which was awesome
it's when i
i read like the first seven pages and
just said to myself are you kidding me
this thing this story needs to get out
so with that um
i always have to make that caveat that
when i read this thing it's
if it seems like it's oh wait where'd
that come from or who's that character
it's because i'm not reading the whole
thing
and you you have to get the book to
really
to follow your story and it is
chronological you know it starts off in
november of 2014 and it ends up
close to 2019 i think but it is
chronological
but it's also it's it moves around from
location to location
story to story because sometimes you're
in baghdad sometimes you're in raqqa
sometimes you're in
outs on the outskirts of missoula you're
traveling to all these different places
but it's it's way more evident when you
read the book the whole book
rather than me just sitting here reading
um chunks of it so
that's my caveat um
when you are traveling over there just
are you just traveling are you traveling
on an american passport so
uh i became an american citizen in 2017.
so initially i was just australian i was
a green card holder
and then i got my citizenship in 2017.
so and then when you're traveling into a
country so i i was in the military
and so we would have um
an official passport so not a diplomatic
passport which is a black passport
but not a regular american passport
which is a maroon passport
we would have blue passports which said
that we're
official i guess government americans
is there anything that you have that
that gives you some kind of indication
as press
nope journalists are just regular
citizens
nothing special you're rolling in there
yeah
who's supplying you with gear who's
giving you body armor who's giving you
helmets
stuff like that so very very i did i did
have my
we we all generally as journalists we
all have our own or
i arranged to wherever i'm going to get
any training
yeah yeah what kind of truth is this
sort of basic you know
uh hostage training just kind of the
basic first aid
um you just kind of have to do a few
basic things
you go but most of my training was
really on the ground
and the approach that i decided to take
really early on which i think
served me and it's probably the approach
that i will always take
is very under the radar so i would see
people that went in with especially and
it's very difficult with television
because television crews have to go in
with
cameras and they go in with a lot of
security and
you become very visible for me i went
in i would organize to meet with locals
wherever it is i was going my local
fixer
a local house i'd be staying in and
i would just very much go under the
radar and to me that was always the way
that i felt that i could get the story
and even though people thought oh you
have to have security you have to have
this you have to have that
i never felt i needed that i felt that
that would have made me more
of a known presence which would have
been
you know more dangerous for me as a
writer i felt that i didn't need
a lot of those things and that was
always you know and i discussed
those things with my with my superiors
and ahead of time
and and that was always something that
they took
um you know enabled me to make those
decisions and
and be that independent and how good was
your arabic
it was okay for a while where did you
learn you know i grew up so where i was
going to school was a
sort of there was a big lebanese
community there so i would just i was so
interested i just i
would have people teach me and so but i
always worked with the translator
because i
couldn't pick up the dialects i mean the
dialects were just so confusing and i
didn't want to risk
ever i guess getting something that
would have been crucial in getting it
wrong
yeah i know the the locals ability to
to understand and give you these nuanced
things you know the interpreters that we
had would you know because we'd have
we'd have americans like seals that had
been trained
to speak arabic and god bless them
they'd do their best
but like you just they they'd be
standing side by side with a native
speaker
and you know my seal interpreter would
say hey the local guy said this and then
the
the native speaker would say hey here's
what he's actually means and
there's just a little bit that you're
just not gonna catch you know it's just
not gonna happen
so you you definitely um it's like
trying to
trying to tell the difference between
you know someone that's from new york
and someone that's from new jersey
right there there's people that can go
oh yeah guys from jersey that guy's from
new york
you know and the same thing overseas
and you are correct here's here's the
weird thing about what you said about
security is a low profile
99 of the time is gonna be
better no one's gonna notice you no
one's gonna care
what people freak out about is there's
that one percent of the time
and then what do you do and then you
weigh those out because it's only if
there's only a tiny chance of something
happening and then you're in a really
bad situation because you don't have any
security
that's horrible but when you have
security you increase the chances
so much that it's a gamble this is
always a gamble
and i always felt very comfortable in
the fixes and the people that i used
locally that
that they had sort of the know-how to at
least you know with exit plans and other
things like that and i always had
contacts in the us in the region and
other places that if i was desperate
that i could
i could turn to if i if i needed to how
did you go about finding your fixers
it generally i mean it depended a sort
of assignment by assignment but
i usually went through either other
journalists who
gave referrals for people that they'd
worked with or people that i knew that
were living there with other businesses
that had used different interpreters
it really really depended on on that but
usually it's always word of mouth i
would never just pluck
somebody off facebook and and
expect them to to be a fixer it'd always
be
several layers of people who could sort
of vet and and work for them and then
do a little bit of my own background
digging on them and just
try to make sure and you can never get
it right there i mean there's plenty of
situations and
unfortunately where journalists have
been sold out and other things and we
saw that a lot in syria
with isis but in uh in my case i always
worked with some really just incredible
people
i've got all kinds of scenarios running
through my head right now
i i when i look back at my life
my whole life in my entire life from the
time i was born until
like two days ago i always think about
all the things that i've done where i
look back and say man that wasn't too
smart oh god
do you do that much i was i was thinking
about it that i thought the things that
i did
not just in iraq but you know other
places in yemen and afghanistan and
in my 20s and i just would never do them
now i would never do them now i look
back and i think what
what were you thinking or or i guess
when
almost in the beginning
and this is where experience comes into
it you almost maybe it's not it's
naivete you don't always know what
you're getting yourself
into and you get out of it and you're
fine and then i
i look back on it now and i think that
was so stupid
what were you thinking like that was not
worth the story
you mean did you even get a story out of
that like yeah
yeah as i read your book i mean that's
what i was thinking
you know there's a lot of you got lucky
a lot which is
awesome you know you had a massive
amount of courage goes into these
which is awesome and that was i wanted
to ask you that
like did you feel do you feel looking
back like now like you you were a little
naive
at the time and obviously
sometimes a little bit of naivety
and arrogance is really nice when you
look back at it if it went well
yeah which it certainly did for you
awesome
all right i'm going to jump into this
book
the first boy to introduce himself was a
nine-year-old named abdullah
he struck me with his light eyes
gap-tooth smile and spattering of
freckles across his nose there was a
gentleness to it
to his demeanor i wondered how such
gentleness could come from a child that
had been ripped from his home
by war abdullah
told us that he was a muslim from sinjar
or sinjal as they say in kurdish
he had been forced to flee two months
earlier when isis invaded his village
he insisted on showing us around the
camp annotated annotating
like a proud tour guide he explained the
different people who lived there
and where they were all from he
explained how they had been confronted
with the same vicious enemy and how they
coped in different ways
some isis we knew abdullah said some of
our neighbors became isis too
i did not know then that such a phrase
would be repeated time and time again as
the years went on
i did not realize then the importance of
that phrase
the clefs and all the conspiracies that
would come from it
that one phrase would come to represent
the fissures of a country
that i wasn't sure could ever be put
back together
our neighbors became isis too
and you know something that i failed to
do as i put these notes together
is is you throughout the book you you
pick these characters
and you revisit them and i get some of
them but i don't get all of them i'm not
sure if i get back to abdullah
but that's what you do so as people hear
me sort of talk about these different
characters
just look the book is 450 pages long
and so if people are wondering like oh i
wonder what happened to that kid or what
happened to that character
many of the characters that you become
close with
you revisit over the years and and as i
said the length of the book is
five years or four four and a half years
something like that there's a lot i mean
think of a
a kid that's you know 10 years old
becomes 14
that's a big difference and and
obviously there also
are characters that you never see again
and god knows what happens to them
um fast forward a little bit here
the soldiers at the mosul dam greeted us
warmly
the peshmerga began and you this i'm
giving everyone a background in
peshmerga what you do
and look you give all kinds of nice
little history lessons in here too the
peshmerga began as something
of a mountain militia in the 1920s when
the push for
kurdish independence began in recent
decades they had faced
unrelenting persecution from the bath
loyalist and
of former iraqi dictator saddam hussein
one peshmerga fighter told me they don't
suffer from psychological issues
pertaining to combat because they have
grown up around fighting and have
developed an early understanding
that it is just what we have to do to
them ptsd
was something of a first world
phenomenon
we worked with um kurdish soldiers
sometimes in the iraqi army
and they were just really good and
they just were really good they have
that that's why that that
that's what they do they grow up
fighting that's sort of their thing
it's like when you're in the u.s
military and you meet someone
that's from you know wyoming and they
grew up
hunting and living out in the land and
they're going to be good soldiers that's
just how it is somebody from alabama
that grew up in the woods
they're going to be a good soldier
that's just how it is that's that's how
you feel about the courage that's how i
always felt about the crime and just
because they say they don't
suffer from any psychological problems
doesn't mean they don't and that's
just a very different relationship that
they have with it
and not just the peshmerga but in a lot
of the you know in the middle east in
those
in the armies and things it's just not
something that they
they acknowledge or really talk about
yeah
and in many ways it's something that we
haven't talked about
up until these most recent wars yep
even though it's always been there
you continue on here the peshmerga
soldiers range from around 18
to more than 70 years old with many
coming out of retirement in the quest to
defeat isis threat
during days of intense conflict the
peshmerga are lucky to return to their
base for two or three hours of sleep
and a quick bite to eat before venturing
back to their fighting
locus as it stood a prominent portion of
the fighters are not soldiers but what
they call
security advisors who don't take a
salary and volunteered simply out of
devotion
there are special forces that have been
arranged for these people
they don't register their names and
don't sign contracts they just want to
serve in kurdistan
one peshmerga soldier explained how isis
commanders often drug
young fighters with special tablets that
leave them disoriented
and shooting wildly into the night
sometimes they were able to keep going
despite being shot several times taking
upwards of 20 bullets before they went
down
for those who survive and that's in
reference to the isis fighters
when they realize what they've done they
sometimes regret it
and you say here almost every kurd wants
to
share their history history of their
people and their oppression
but the string that could be weaved
through and through was that they did
not expect to be granted freedom for
nothing
they knew they would have to fight for
every fight for it every step of the way
the secession of let downs of losses and
gains was all part of their rough climb
up the road
of revolution at the top they would find
their independence
when they referred to their soldiers
killed on the battlefield they sometimes
said that they were martyred and
sometimes said that they were murdered
i wondered how differently americans
would see wars
if the press and the people spoke of our
troops in the firing line as having died
in a homicide
rather than killed in action and and now
you
kind of reflect on this battle that had
taken place the rain fell harder
the bullets flew wildly into the growing
darkness that hid the dead isis bodies
nearby
hungry untamed dogs had gouged into the
skeletons almost immediately
some had been dead for days some had
names and others had been left nameless
some maculated by the creatures howling
at the moon
had no faces
so you jump right into this stuff with
i mean this battle that's taking place
up at the mosul dam you're seeing the
isis fighters
this is a a long way from
paris hilton's malibu beach parties i
guess definitely
and and when i first went and i didn't
go with the intention of
of going to the front lines i i really
went with the intention of trying to
understand
i guess the human cost of war and i
really just wanted to go and talk to
people that lived there i wanted to
understand
what it was like to to be a displaced
person
what it was like to to sort of have
everything and and then have nothing
and i just happened to sort of make a
good connection through
through somebody and then when i went to
meet him
it was a crazy story he he came we
picked us up
the car got stuck in the mud and
there was sort of a lot of fighting
going on and so we sort of had to
go to go in a different direction and
then we ended up sort of on the front
line so it wasn't something that even
really planned and
i'm sure my bosses would have had a
heart attack if i'd sort of told them in
advance
but yeah it was it was a it was a night
very eye opening
and even when i
i guess the times that i've spent with
the peshmerga with other soldiers iraqi
soldiers on the front line it's always
still being that same theme for me of
wanting to get that human cost
so i'm much more interested in in those
stories i guess
from my perspective than than what we
call the the bang bang is what
journalists usually call it the sort of
the more military aspect of it
i wanted to understand who who they were
who their families were
what their motivation for being there
was as you said it's you know these
people coming out
and volunteering and and they're not
getting paid and they're bringing their
ak-47 from home
and they don't really have much more
beyond that and i just that to me was
fascinating what is it
what is motivating you what is driving
you what
what are you sacrificing to do this and
do you plan to just keep doing this
over and over again i think for me that
was always the question that i was
trying to
trying to understand or trying to piece
together in my head
yeah and as i'm sitting here thinking
about you on the front lines for the
first time sort of
and then going back to the the
conversation we had about
being naive and i just i just remembered
a conversation first of all i've had
this conversation with a bunch of
but the one that came to my mind was a
guy by the name of dean ladd
who is a marine in world war ii who
went on the island campaign and
he was going into tarawa as a marine
as a marine platoon commander or company
commander i forget which
but i there was this was an insane
operation they could tell it was going
to be insane you know they're going to
storm the beaches where the japanese had
been
dug in for three years and he did this
over and over again
but i i you know i said well did you
think anything might happen to you he
said that's always going to happen to
the other guy
which is what everybody thinks which is
what everybody thinks
and you know that's what that's what i
think you know
that's probably gonna happen to somebody
else but not me yeah and i think just
i guess by nature you know with a lot of
journalists whether they've had
you know tremendous years behind them
doing this or not it's
i guess it's that same notion of
you know we're not working for the
government we're not working for
anyone in particular you know beyond our
organizations
and so you sort of have this kind of
strange freedom
no one is telling you what to do you
know and and
and for me i guess i i really wanted to
take advantage of that
in and just yeah be i remember one time
being it
um did you ever go to taji air base just
outside of baghdad i think i
flew through there but i never spent
anything i spent a bit of time there and
i was with the aussies and then i
we were supposed to go to al-assad and
on the uh to the marine base there and
there was just dust storm after dust
storms every flight was getting
cancelled i was like i just want to go
back to baghdad i was trying to get a
uh interview with satur and i was just
let's just go to baghdad
and i couldn't couldn't get back to
baghdad and so i was literally just
calling a cab from taji to like come and
get me so i could drive back to my hotel
and meet my fixer in baghdad
i remember the aussies were standing
there going you're just
crazy and that's probably really jealous
i was like yeah i can i can do that yeah
and what's interesting going back to the
earlier conversation
if you were to take a convoy back
from there to baghdad you would probably
be at
a greater risk much greater risk than if
you were in a cab an orange and white
opal freaking taxi cab that are driving
all over the place
yeah yeah and i i would do that to work
i i remember going through like all
these iranian militia checkpoints
i was would be in these yazidi cars with
a baby on my lap
pretending i was a yazidi you know i put
the scarf over my head
there's a baby in my lap i think i
managed to get through about a hundred
of these iranian
shia checkpoints and not one of them
questioned me
and i remember just getting out of that
being like oh had i
and i know of other journalists i knew a
couple of people and they
they got busted at checkpoints and
turned around or turned in or
whatever it was and and for me that was
going under the radar i got to where i
needed to be
had i even got the checkpoint permission
slips that you're supposed to get
i would i wouldn't have gotten through
so sometimes you just got to not play by
the rules
under the radar that's the theme
i got one more maybe it's not the last
one but earlier in the book there are
some history lessons
like i said even though most of the book
is more
just interviews with people and and what
you're actually seeing
this is a little history lesson on march
17th 1988 the morning after saddam
hussein's bath party
unleashed a tirade of chemical weapons
and killed five thousand iraqi kurds in
the city of
halabja halabja
a few brave photojournalists ventured
into the city
to ensure the brutal dictators
atrocities would be documented and
exposed to the world
and you're you're now interacting with
one of them akram looked at me shyly
extending his hand
nearly 27 years later he was working at
the memorial site
known as the halabja monument and peace
museum
constructed in 2003 on the anniversary
of the attack in 2006
residents thousands of residents rioted
at the site protesting
what they thought was to be capitalizing
on the tragedy
and misusing aid funds destroying many
of the archives
the monument was rebuilt into a hub of
reflection and solace
poised against the serene iranian
mountainside
with several abandoned bath party tanks
sitting idly to one side
inside the iconic photographs taken in
the pallid
aftermath of the attacks had been
recreated as life-sized images and
statues
a mother clutching her dead baby
lifeless children strewn across
pavements
and here's akram talking we need to
remind the new generation
about what happened to this town and we
need to keep reminding them
so that it doesn't happen again
sometimes i can't stop crying every day
i look at the pictures and i am reminded
that it is my family in those pictures
end quote
there's there was such a depth of
sadness in the way he shared a story
constantly relieving
a cursed reliving accursed history sodom
had ordered the chemical attack
amid the iran-iraq war following intel
reports that iranian
soldiers had been implanted inside the
kurdish city
akram still didn't seem quite sure how
or
why his life was spared or why he was
the only survivor
within the proximate area he recalled
having
instinctively placed his mother's scarf
around his mouth
for protection the moment something felt
wrong
he recalled throwing up blood into the
scarf
which still smelled of his mother even
though she was dead beside him
he recalled the way the vision blur his
vision blurred slowly
fading into blackness he remembered cars
rolling over bodies as other victims
in their last few minutes on earth
vomited chunks of green
some were visibly burning their skin
boiling with bubbles
others laughed uncontrollably
an eerie side effect of the lethal
chemical cocktail
of vx vx sarin taboon
and mustard gas
[Applause]
that's a a chilling vision
what kind of health was this guy in now
was he scarred
yeah he definitely i mean he
was rel looked normal but
there was something about him i can't
put my finger on it but there was
definitely something that
that was wasn't quite right
fast forward a little bit there's a
section called the faces of
evil this is november 2014. some isis
soldiers will tell you
that the reason they joined were simple
straightforward
woven into the web of basic survival
money protection food
other times their reasons to pledge
allegiance to the terrorist group were
complex
deep-seated in sectarian tribal and
historical grievances
dating back centuries so
what is war war is a composite
of individual stories and reasons one
rarely the same as the other and you
know i pointed out in the introduction
that you asked this question
over and over again more times than i
read maybe that's the first time you
asked
ask the question but
that's what's interesting about that
answer it's a composite of individual
stories and reasons and that's what this
book is
is like you're compiling all these
different
perspectives that people have what
they've been through and how they ended
up here
did you have that intent when did this
work that you were doing start to
formulate in your head
as a congruent story that you could put
together in a book
it was something i guess it's funny most
of this book
was written handwritten in notebooks so
you can imagine how many of those are
sitting in storage right now um but yeah
i think from
sort of the first in in 2014 i was
trying to craft together
how i wanted to read these stories and
and what
how to make it a bigger story and i just
i knew that i didn't want to write
something that was
political or policy driven or i just i
didn't feel that that was my job
as a journalist i wasn't here to change
laws i wasn't here to to become or to be
a quote-unquote
expert in in anything my job
was to tell a story that was what i knew
and that's what i knew that i could do
and so for me it was it was early on
that i started to shape that idea and i
didn't quite know
how to put it together and then i guess
around 20
end of 2015 i thought you know this is
the approach i want to take with it i
really have to be patient
because you're gonna have to stick this
out for a few more years this isn't
something that you can
work on and finish in the next couple of
months so i had to give myself a good
lesson
lesson in patience and and just continue
to
to spend the next few years just going
back and forth and
and spending as much time as i possibly
could on the ground
and then i guess i felt that i hadn't
and i could have kept going that was the
thing i just i could have kept going i
could be there now and keep going
and still have these incredible stories
but
at some point i had to realize okay you
need to stop
and you know there are other other
things you need to do the other places
you need to focus but there also has to
be a beginning and an end to this
so yeah i guess it was sort of 2019 that
i i decided that
i think i had enough to to put something
together
but but have you ever read hiroshima
no oh it's one of the most incredible
incredible books about
japan and it was a journalist who'd gone
back and he was telling stories there's
individual stories decades after it and
it had such a lasting effect on me
um growing up and and that was sort of i
guess one of the biggest motivations in
in
the style that i took with it was
again that human cost and then just
telling
telling the very narrative story from as
many perspectives
as possible and and as much detail as i
possibly could as well and i think that
was something i i wanted to bring out
was
it's those small details that make up
the big ones and i
i think it's the individual stories that
tell
a big picture and sometimes we can look
at statistics and we can look at
these things that really distance us
from a conflict because it's really easy
to do that you can say okay well
202 people died in that suicide attack
but you tell the story of one person who
died in that suicide attack and it's
probably going to have a much more
profound
impact on you and that's what i wanted
to drive home was how the individual
stories make up the big story
it's the micro in the macro yeah and
that's um
very reflective of the way i
well with this podcast of course do we
cover some
big you know general patton's books yes
we do but
the majority of the books that we cover
on here are written by
a lance corporal or a corporal or a
private
that's out there in the front lines
carrying a machine gun
because once again when you when you're
talking about what the general saw or
what the general did
there's a there's an altitude there
there's a lack of connection
in many cases as to what actually is
happening on the ground and
and what that looks like down there so
yeah your your effort to do that
absolutely came through and that example
of the suicide bombing yeah i
see a statistic of 202 people are killed
in suicide bombing
you can read that and you can move on
you can you can re-see that
headline and read you know what city was
in and cool you got the information you
can move on
when you read about one of those victims
their family
how it's going to impact them what mark
it's going to leave how they ended up
there in the first place
what their goals and dreams were like
that's
that's the impact
and by the way it's not always good as
is the case here
with omar back to the book omar a 25
year old
isis fighter from the iraqi village of
dor saladin admitted that during
isis's first month in mosul he had
killed scores of his countrymen
and foreign contractors on their behalf
quote they came to our area and forced
me to protect their lands omar said
flatly of his isis commanders his thick
mono brow remaining frighteningly still
a physical manifestation of the
emotionless
figure before me after a while they told
me
when are you going to start protecting
your own land
his eyes burning into mind he went on to
describe the words of his superiors
they told me to do it or die and then
they killed people in front of me
by his count he had racked up 70
executions
in a matter of months he mandated that
he killed his victims
with rifle shots and was chillingly
candid
about why he did it
yeah it's it's fascinating
that you're sitting face to face with
these these individuals and obviously
you have a knack for getting people to
talk
because throughout the book you're
getting people to explain things to them
to you that are either a in incredibly
painful
or b incriminating like that
somehow you're getting these people to
talk it's very impressive
you'd be surprised how many people want
a platform you know
get them to talk and they they they want
to
and often i think a lot of it came down
to they just hadn't talked to anyone for
a while so they were ready to talk to
someone
and they wanted to tell their story and
you get them going for
a minute and they're spilling their life
to you because
they've been you know locked up or
whatever the situation is and
people like to listen to themselves
speak and and that's what i've certainly
found
in interviewing a number of different
jihadists and
they want to talk you say here
the facilities director of security
noted that most isis fighters were
uneducated and easily led down the
grisly path
of violent jihad some regret their
actions some do not the guard said to me
earlier
nonchalantly understand that most are
young and have no information
they are impressionable they listen to
the second life
paradise story 72 virgins
rivers of wine and staying young forever
that is all they know
and you look there's pl there's so many
interviews in here
with all these different people you've
gotta get the book to read through them
they're powerful i guess i
got drawn into this section a star
spangled love
the notion of giving thanks the red
white and blue was not lost on the
people of kurdistan
the bald eagle old glory and the
almighty american dollar were king in
the kurdish part of iraq most
ethnic kurds did not hide their
affection for the u.s
a concept that had become rare in the
predominantly anti-american throngs of
the middle east
shops peddled american flags us military
gear was prized and the locals spoke
glowingly of the notion of the nation
they created
with removing saddam hussein the
dictator whose heavy hand
had so often come down on the minority
group clustered
into the northern region imagine if
america didn't exist
said accountant kurdo amin aga
whose home was outfitted with israeli
american and kurdistan flags
and who wears a u.s army shirt and a
navy seal watch
without america the world would be run
by china or iran
dewy eyes he turned to me in earnest
america represents freedom he stressed
our dream is to be eternally allied to
america
you don't hear a lot about that yeah
that was it was fascinating yeah when
you go
it was this little pocket of i mean the
kurds in the north they just
they loved they loved both bushes they
you know it was just something that they
just
they thought america was the the ones to
save the day
yeah i mean you go in and talk about how
you're walking through uh
the like the bazaar has red white and
blue has flags and all this stuff in
there
just pro america pro freedom yeah
and this is also interesting kurds who
as a group
are overwhelmingly muslim also portrayed
themselves as
more religiously tolerant right now i'm
working with muslims
yazidi christians we're all working
together said
one high-ranking krg official they
celebrate occasions together
it's something very beautiful i have
friends who pray and friends who don't
that's not my problem that is their
choice
that is how the kurdish people think
about religion
on one early december morning i saw
several kurds busily setting up a
and decorating christmas trees
whether it was done in a secular embrace
of a foreign religious
right or simply to make guests more
comfortable was not clear
we're still new to this a kurdish hotel
employee said with a smile
bickering with a co-worker on how to
decorate the tree but we love it
very tolerant yeah
setting up christmas trees yeah during
the
uh after the 2003 uh iraq invasion
they marketed they had an entire tourism
marketing campaign called the other iraq
and that was sort of how they would try
to draw people in to come and visit
them was this other iraq they call
themselves
so even though they belong to iraq they
tried to be the other so that was their
kind of approach
beautiful
fast forward a little bit that summer i
drifted between displacement camps
the big ones and the small ones the ones
that were new only just established to
accommodate
this constant swell of newcomers the
ones that have been here for years
as past wars melted into new wars over
time the camps
had burst in into little towns of their
own complete with banks and bridal
stores and markets and places to buy
home goods and sweaters
what is war war brings resiliency
it is turning what feels like a prison
into something of a home
what is war war is running it is not
knowing what is on the other side
it is being unwelcome in your own home
is being unwelcome
away from your home sometimes war is
walking too
one moment here and the next in some no
man's land
that you could that could never be home
it was drifting from place to place both
in mind
and body
crazy to think these camps are set up
for so long that they become little
villages
yeah and and what's really sad is that
so many of them still exist
and because i guess it's really out of
sort of the main headlines of the news
now they just the resources are just
there's nothing the likes of bassemer
and gazelle they're
still in camps just with nothing and and
no resources so it's almost even a worse
situation for
for so many of the displaced now than i
it was for
them four years ago
you say here in a small camp designated
especially for displaced christians
a group of men looked me in the eyes and
said sternly that they do not bother
trying to read or watch the news anymore
because it was all fraudulent all lies
as you're hearing that does that make
you think okay i've got to tell the
truth i mean i just can't
i can only imagine hearing that from
your perspective yeah
yeah for them i think they've just grown
so frustrated i think
when you see such astrologies happen in
the beginning you really believe that
there's no way the world's just gonna
sit there and do nothing i mean this is
crazy somebody's gonna do something
someone's gonna stop this
and then you reach a point a year in
maybe it's 18 months in
when you realize it's it's not well it's
not that simple but
it's just not the situation's not
changing and so for them i think that
was just the acceptance that
the news was never going to help them
nobody was ever going to help them and
so they
they'd come to that sort of group
rationale of they mustn't be telling the
truth
because if they were telling the truth
then this wouldn't be happening
if the world knew what was really
happening it would have been stopped by
now so therefore
it must be all lies
how much how much do you think these
stories get lost because
of the short attention span of the world
i think very lost i think
i think very lost which is why i guess i
wanted to try to put it at least
together as as one cohesive unit
the attention span is is short but i
think it's always been
telling foreign stories has always been
difficult
i talked to journalists covering it was
in the 90s
with um you know with bosnia and other
places and they said the same thing it
would you know princess diana did
something and it would take the
headlines
and then for me it was sort of you know
something would happen
you know kim kardashian breaking the
internet and that would take the
headlines
and so i think it's always a thing where
no matter what
error that you're in that foreign news
unfortunately isn't going to
always be at the top but that doesn't
mean we don't report on it
that doesn't mean we don't give it
resources that doesn't mean we don't
tell a story
and for me that was what i was drawn to
was the stories that i felt needed to be
told
whether they have an impact or not that
that is out of my hands
but those voices deserve to be heard
this is a good segue into this section
which is
entitled don't forget us
early one morning i ventured further
north to visit a yazidi camp stuffed
into the wedge where syria
iraq and turkey converge as it came into
view over hilltop's awash with the midst
of equity air i ascertained a sense of
something profoundly exhausting
what struck me most was that unlike
other camps where people
animatedly voiced their anger and wailed
about the lack of
water sharing conspiracy theories about
who was really behind isis
and detailing what had happened to them
in the flashes
after they realized they could no longer
stay the yazidis were so grieved
that they said very little
they did not complain they just looked
at me with wide
eyes that could brand even the most
stoic of souls they all spoke softly
repeating that they all they wanted was
for their family members to return
and for the chance to go home every
single person
had either lost a family member to death
or disappearance or had been maimed when
isis assaulted their village less than a
year earlier
it did not make sense for them to
complain to complain would be a waste of
their precious energy
i was escorted into a tent where a thin
woman had burrowed herself into the
corner
weeping silently into her black scarf
shoulders trembling
she was a survivor of sex slavery
she was alive but she was hardly living
more girls and women tiptoed into the
tent behind me nobody wanted to speak of
this ordeal
the notion of being touched
the term sex slave is a controversial
one many decry
that it should not be used that it was
not politically correct nor accurate
an argument which i hear and understand
but i have chosen to use it because it
is a term that many of the survivors and
families use
and because it's blunt and embedded in
the reality that is
not the reality that we want speaking of
rape was taboo
and terrifying within the closed and
staunchly conservative yazidi community
although the silence was slowly shifting
but there inside that suffocating space
the women held each other up their
embraces reassuring each other
that they were now safe if only for that
moment in time
and at that moment in time i understood
that the most valuable thing i owned was
my 99 cent
notebook with which i could try to
capture the plight of these survivors
in hopes that somehow they would not
tumble from the world's oblivion
it was with my notebook that i could
recall and write things these women
taught me
what it meant to be extraordinary what
it meant to be brave
what it meant to lose everything and
still find the internal spark
to go on
we'll get into more of the the yazidi
treatment i mean it's just a genocide
slash i mean the isis viewed them as
satan worshipers yeah devil worshipers
yeah
other end of the spectrum
this section stood out to me
one evening i met emerging pop star
hallie love for tea and hookah
in the lounge hookah in the lounge of an
ups of the upscale
rotana hotel in erbil she was dolled up
to the nines with long perfect bleached
hair extensions
fake eyelashes red lips and strappy
stilettos that clashed with their
camouflage military pants
in and loose-fitting white top by
recording techno-driven
energy-boosting tunes to increase morale
and filming
music videos in the direct line of fire
heli was doing what she considered to be
her
part in the fight standing vehemently
with the soldiers and their will to win
much had been said and speculated about
helly's personal life
and i wasn't quite sure what to expect
but what i found was a true girls girl
underneath the hairspray and larger than
life persona helly was a self-assured
young woman who sought only to use her
stardom and musical talents for
something more than milking the
hollywood machine
some say i used to be i use the
peshmerga to further my own fame but
people will always complain she said
bluntly
in her sharply accented english flicking
a perfectly manicured hand
my country is bleeding and my weapon is
my voice and my music
and for those who have had their voices
shot i felt this was my only way of
bringing their story the story of the
kurdish people
to the world
helly love i love telly she was lovely
she was she was born in iran
became a refugee ended up in finland
from there got put into a music school
of some kind
um and and then
the lore of hollywood got a hold of her
she says this very quickly i saw the e
so she ends up in hollywood yeah she
lives in the hospital she's living in
hollywood yeah doing
doing the uh i think she got signed to
one of the big labels i think
uh dream or one of those big you know
producers had signed her and then you
know what happens is you often kind of
get
sort of shelved away and then yeah she
really really shoved away
so the labels will sign you and you
offer you a deal and then they actually
just don't you know you never get kind
of to actually release and so once the
contract is up you can kind of move on
so i think i'm not sure of all her
details but i think she was sort of
brought over here and
and it was sort of starry-eyed and then
nothing kind of moved and she really saw
the underbelly of
of water what hollywood was yeah she
said she said i met some producers and
realized that what they were offering in
exchange to promote me was a lie
it was all about sex it was shocking to
me i gave up on almost everything
she ends up cutting a cut in a couple
songs over there
she says straight away i received death
threats from radical islamic groups
and the mullahs at the mosque were
insisting i was a bad influence and
should be stoned to death
my life changed i was the lion girl i
had all these fans and all the success
but i had to contend with this too you
can watch your videos on youtube and i
definitely recommend checking them out
yeah that's something else right yeah
even echo charles would be proud because
she has a lot of explosions
and she's filming it's like yeah
literally i remember
she was filming and getting you know
controversial some people agree some
people won't but yeah isis is five miles
or something down the road and she's
filming a music video
[Music]
yeah um how'd she and you this is one of
the things i don't really trace but you
traced
the rest of her story you go back and
visit her at some point don't you yeah
so i went back
and because yeah i always wondered and i
really
i really loved telly when i met her and
so i went back when i was in nebeal and
her name came up with a friend of mine
there and she'd opened
a beauty school or a sort of big beauty
salon
and everything was very pink and and you
know all the young girls will
go there for their you know their
equivalent of the prom and
and get ready and and i think she'd
really settled into that kind of life
of of being able to to be
in with her people and and to do things
in a really different way than than she
didn't
envision so yeah that was her way of i
guess giving back in a new evolution was
to
sort of be the the
the motivator for a lot of the the young
girls in sort of the next generation
yeah i thought that was that was awesome
it's like she
she like you always hear people um
going back to your roots you know go
back through she straight up went back
to her roots
and she lives there now and pretty
awesome
yeah then she does have some pumped up
videos
and she's gorgeous
uh i'm gonna fast forward up to 2016.
this brazen attack struck deep when no
one was ready for it there had been no
intelligence warnings
an isis suicide bomber detonated at a
checkpoint outside a small town
called dbs near kirkuk on november
3rd 2015 allowing three
fellow fighters to sneak through and
temporarily
commandeer a local government off office
the men were sentenced to hell and all
died in the attack
but the isis bomb expert whose handiwork
sent them to their maker did not
jasim mohammed atiyah
was being held in a high security prison
near the oil rich city
in late january of 2016 the guards let
jessem blindfolded into the room to meet
me
what i did were terror acts justine the
22 year old
said matter-of-factly sitting handcuffed
in the small office in the
erbil headquarters of the of assaya
it was my duty there are infidel
infidels
and there is instruction in the quran to
stop
this and to fight all infidels
the kurdish security forces had nabbed
jasim
weeks after the attack that slaughtered
14 kurds
and left scores more wounded three isis
fighters had used the checkpoint bombing
as a diversion to enter the city
then briefly hold themselves up in the
mayor's office
the standoff ended when they opted to
blow their own bodies to bits as police
forces closed in
while that attack served as notice that
isis was able to strike outside the
territory it controlled
the one thwarted by jazeem's capture
would have been devastating by
comparison
the kurdish security officials told me
that jasim had been preparing to rig
a powerful truck bomb bound for erbil
when he was arrested by intelligence
agents
jasim had cried like a big baby when he
was seized
one intelligence officer recalled smugly
and had cried that allah would be mad at
him
the authorities relished any opportunity
to take away the perceived power of isis
members
to bellow that these fighters were
nothing more than pathetic delusional
con artists
the exact number of deaths caused by the
exact number of deaths
jazeem caused whether directly or
indirectly remained
unclear he repeatedly gloated about
conducting operations that killed and
harmed scores of people including the
fighters he outfitted with suicide vests
or put behind the wheels of vehicles
rigged to explode
he was proud of his monstrous work and
craftsmanship
but he was by no means ready to be a
martyr himself
when i asked if he would have strapped a
vest on
of his own i never thought of killing
myself
i'm not convinced to kill myself he said
unapologetically
actually i would leave or escape if they
gave me this order
i wouldn't explode myself that is
another level of
faith he was unconvinced by the mullah's
routine
espousing the paradise replete with 72
virgins
that don't menstruate or defecate it's
our leaders that make decisions
jazeem said our scientists
our scientists say that there are
infidel people in kirkuk
it is not my decision we are students
and we listen to our teachers
if somebody pledges allegiance to isis
they must take orders and do whatever
orders they
get they have to do it
i asked about the scientists and their
theoretical determinations of infidel
blood
but he didn't seem to know jazim had
been taught not to question the
scientists
if the scientists were really scientists
but at the top of
isis of the isis hierarchy was
abu bakr al-baghdadi who jazeem
described as a good leader
who lived as a simple soldier and who
was just like everyone else
he had never met or seen the elusive
self-professed isis
khalif
it's dangerous to meet him no one can
see him jazeem said his eyes widening in
surprise
that even suggested such a question it
is prohibited for anybody to see him
alternating between bravado and
circumspection
brought on by either remorse or the
presence of a watchful jailer
jasim chorus that he would have to be
convinced not to go back to isis if he
were released
before i went to prison i had no
problems killing people now i have a bit
of regret
that maybe some people don't deserve to
be killed
how long would you sit in a room with
these guys for really depended i think
with him it was around about
an hour to two hours so
how would you select who you would you
just say hey
who do you got yeah i would usually talk
to the guards about
who was there who was willing to talk i
always wanted to make it very clear
uh to them you know i was a journalist
um and their stories were going to be
you know as as they told them and and
they needed to be
it was difficult because in some cases
they hadn't been brought to trial
so you know when they're saying these
things
you know and you haven't been brought to
trial yet you are incriminating yourself
to a degree
and so i always wanted to be very fair
and very clear that i'm a journalist and
what you say is going to be printed
so their willingness was obviously a big
factor in in them
coming forward and telling their stories
yeah he also said it's better if they
join
we want to go to america we want to
spread our ideology all over the world
you talked to another guy sahir sahib
jamel
by his count he had killed dozens of
uninvolved men women and children
he says at the beginning isis told us we
would all go to heaven but now that i'm
in prison it means i am
going to the fire i am going to hell
the indoctrination was self-fulfilling
fantasy script was evident
but any sign of real remorse was not
real quick when you interview these
people you mentioned that
that one guy was blindfolded is he
blindfolded during the interview as well
or they
they take it off yeah they blindfold
them when they bring them in so they
don't really know i guess
exactly where they are you know specific
office or whatever they're i'm not
yeah but they they take it off normally
i mean he was
he uh still had chuckles and on but they
they took the blindfold off
isn't that weird just looking at him in
his eyes when he's telling you all this
stuff
um at first it is there's a little bit
of a warm-up process and
and i found in a couple of the
situations where my fixes would get very
angry and i would have to ask them to
leave or
you know because often
you know it's it's their relatives it's
their you know people that have been
killed by these people and they
their hate is so strong that sometimes i
i felt that i'm not going to get a great
interview right now because
you know you can feel that animosity and
the reason i'm i'm trying to get them to
open up here
so you know there was that barrier i had
to deal with a little bit in the
beginning and then
i think as you sort of move into it you
kind of get a
you build that rapport to a degree they
realize you're just there to talk to
them to have a conversation it's not
it's not my job to i'm not there to
interrogate you i'm not there to
you know to to stick it to the man i'm
just there to find out the information
so once i think they get um
used to me a little bit and then you
know i get used to them a little bit
then it can
become a little bit more of a
conversation after that isn't it
would you compare you know how like the
doctor's right like a surgeon or
something like this and they gotta cut
somebody open complimentary
yeah like for a normal person they'd be
like i don't know if i can cut this
person open
but then if you're a doctor after a
while it becomes less of oh i'm cutting
this person open
more like this is like a you know like a
specimen that i have to like work on
kind of thing
yeah i think i mean there is there are
certain degrees of you that you have to
compartmentalize i think for me
i'm always very cautious of not wanting
to do that too much
because i think my you know what i'm
trying to do
is to to really bring a different level
of understanding on all sides of it
and i don't want to be too distant so
it's a fine balance and sometimes you
know and sometimes i make it better than
others
but um yeah it's really
it's just listening often it's just
listening that's what it comes down to
seems like after a while this like all
these stories might kind of jam you up
yeah yeah yeah i did get to that point a
little bit
but i'd set boundaries for myself to
recognize that i think
and yeah i did get to that point
when you say set boundaries for yourself
give us help
because there's a lot of us yeah we
could use some boundaries so i had i had
certain markers i knew for myself really
especially because i was you know
spending so much time and the stories
would just get heavier and heavier and
heavier and i would just be living in
and i'd be living on a floor somewhere
and
i didn't have a team i didn't i didn't
have people around me beyond
you know my fixes and who i was very
close to but
i just knew that i i wouldn't be able to
do my work effectively if
something or i was hearing things that
were really tragic or something tragic
had happened
and i didn't feel anything and
that i think that moment didn't really
come for me during this particular book
um i had a couple of moments where i
just i felt very
broken a little bit because i felt so
helpless and that happened during that
but i still managed to feel
um you know everything affected me and i
wanted it to affect me to a degree
and then when i realized i really needed
to take a break was was
sort of several years after and it was
in i was in africa in east africa
and i'd interviewed a woman from the
congo who
had had you know sexual violence and
she'd had these babies out of rape and
just what she went through was so
horrific and she'd been shunned by her
community and she was running
and she was just the most extraordinary
woman and she was so
her name was nancy and she was so strong
and amazing
and i just remember sitting with her for
hours and with these babies
and having that feeling of oh my god i
don't i don't even feel this i don't i
don't feel anything right now
and that really bothered me that i
didn't feel anything and so after that
trip i
i went home and i i didn't go anywhere i
don't think for about
six or seven months because i just felt
that
yeah if i'd got to that point of just
not reacting that was not the point that
i wanted to get to and that's when
you just have to take a break and that's
it but i think
during the process of this book and i
talk about a little bit in the book
but it's often you know as a as a writer
i think it's an advantage because
you're telling stories and so it's
almost cathartic so people are
telling you terrible things and you have
a way to release it out of your body
whereas i know a lot of my colleagues
who are photographers or videographers
um sort of in combat i think that they
suffer more to be honest and i've heard
this from other journalists because
maybe they're not getting that same
release that i get as a writer
you know may or may not be true but
that's sort of my experience with it but
i know
and i talk about in the book and it's
not always the most obvious
things that i use the word break you but
it's not always
you know digging up the math graves or
or seeing somebody
be killed or you know they're horrific
things but for me
they weren't the things that you know
shattered me the things were
and there's one that that really sticks
out for me and that was in
in sinjar in the city and it had been
completely destroyed and
a few of these very poor people had
moved back
to live in these houses where there was
no water no electricity there was
nothing
and because they couldn't afford to live
at camps even
and so i remember being there one day
and there was a young father and he had
two young children and he was just
living in his old bombed out house even
though there was nothing in there
and he said that he they were yezidi and
he said
that his wife had been taken that the
children's mother
and that the capture had called him and
said if you give me
x amount of dollars it was several
thousand dollars then you know i will
turn her so this poor guy for months
walked around and around the village and
everybody was trying to give him money
and he's selling his furniture and
and you know doing whatever he finally
comes up with the money
and then he calls the the captor and
says hey i've got the money
and he says oh the price has doubled and
at that point
the man just gave up he just gave up he
said i can't i don't have that no one
else is going to give me any more money
and so he's sitting here with these kids
and i just
and that was the story that really
really cracked me because
i felt so helpless and i thought i can't
even give you money because
i would be labeled as a terror you know
giving my financing a terrorist
regime if i did that because they're
paying isis to get
their women back but but to him that was
that was his wife that was these
children's mother and just
the fact that she's probably not even
alive now because he just could not come
up with that money and
he didn't have the resources to do that
it was just it was such a helpless
feeling and i
i couldn't help him and yeah that was
the moment for me that i was like this
is
this is just insanity this is ridiculous
and
and there's no reason that this should
be happening
i think when you talk about the fact
that writing the stories is an
outlet and and it's something that i
talk about with um
even with from a leadership perspective
when i'm talking to leaders about how to
make decisions
i say look when you write something down
you are detaching from it it's
literally on a piece of paper outside of
your head now and now you can assess it
from a different perspective
so i think that i totally agree that
writing
is therapeutic because
you get it out of your system and now
you can see it on the page and you can
relate it from a different
from a different perspective
you know and it's weird you also talked
about
the you know at a point where you
were in africa and you're interviewing
this woman
and she's been through this absolutely
unimaginable horror and she's pressing
on by the way and she's carrying forth
and
you feel like empty and that's you
describe the yazidis at any point
at many points of being in that zone
where they just have no more emotions
left because they've just gotten
crushed at every single turn um and
there was
there was one point there and there
telling me these stories and showing me
the pictures of these yazidi babies that
were being burned and i just i lost it
and
you never want to lose it yeah you know
especially as a journalist you never
want to cry you never want to break down
and i just
i i broke down and
i was just bawling in this room and i
just remember i looked up and if
somebody was handing me a tissue
they're all men in the room yazidi men
and was with one of their religious
leaders
and i just looked at every one of those
faces and i thought
and even one of them just looked at me
and he said we just don't react anymore
and i just thought this is just it's
such a
it's a place beyond a place that i can
you know thank goodness
can never imagine getting to or
hopefully never would but
the depths of what they'd endured the
the thousands of people from their
community that had been taken
and and just it was so hard to even now
to wrap my head around but for them it
was just
they were beyond the point of even
reacting to any of it anymore
then they were just so lost and so so
broken by it all that i just
nothing was triggering them anymore and
so here was i feeling terribly
unprofessional
and crying but i just i couldn't i just
couldn't stop
and it was just you know that was a
probably the only time i've really done
that but that was
yeah it was just a moment for me of
realizing that
here i was feeling terrible and they
weren't even you know
as upset as i was and then i had to
really realize that they were
suffering in a much different way yeah
you also mentioned in the book that
so at one point you felt like that and
then you kind of had to say
i'm a volunteer here like i'm here
because i want to be here
i can be sad but they can't leave this
is it for them
absolutely and there's always a guilt
that comes with that and it's still
something i grapple with
so i can go in and i can spend however
long i want to spend there months
weeks whatever and you get their stories
and you you tell their stories and then
you get to go home
i get to get on a plane i have an
american passport australian impossible
i go home
and they don't they don't get to go home
they don't get to they don't understand
you know
what that that that in itself being such
a luxury
you know and there's a guilt that i i
feel with that
sometimes in just in being there and
they don't view it that way they view it
as why we you know what a gift it is
that someone would want to even come in
and tell their story
and would leave their comfortable home
in their
you know families and come and and and
talk to us and and that's how they view
it which is lovely
but but for me it was always yeah a
sense of
of just feeling a little bit of guilt
about it and and i always tried not to
be a vulture i didn't want to go in
and and have somebody sort of open up
and tell their story and then i and then
i take that story and i leave
um and i don't know that it's ever it's
ever gonna change anything for them i
don't know that it's ever gonna do any
good for them
um so yeah that's something i i
i sit with
what about the sun ladies tell us about
the sun ladies because this is a cool
thing they were extraordinary so yeah i
heard about them
and we went to sort of we went for a
long drive to meet them and they were
these extraordinary yazidi women
most of them had come from sinjar and
and uh
so when when isis came in in 2014 these
the yezidis had to flee up the mountain
because there wasn't anywhere to go it
was all surrounded at the bottom
and the tragedy of it was so many of
them died on that mountain because they
starved to death it was the middle of
summer and
iraq in the summer is something else but
they stopped they were they were
describing you know having to throw
children off the mountain because that
was going to be a better way for them to
die than to to die of starvation or
dehydration and
and that was really what spurred america
to to get back involved
in iraq was the yazidi plan and
the fact that of what happened to them
was just and there was no
it was so hard to get aid and anything
to them so the women that survived that
formed their own unit that they called
the sun ladies the force of the sun
ladies
because they wanted to i think was
multiple reasons but they wanted to
to a find their women that were still
missing and b they wanted to be involved
in that
in that liberation of getting their
towns and villages back and
and they were just really really
extraordinary women
they also wanted vengeance yeah as you
would
as you would yeah i know it's a
very cool section in there that you talk
about um
and and they also had
real a real
situation i mean i'll just go to the
books we have a lot of
our women in mosul being held as slaves
their families are waiting for them we
are waiting for them the liberation
might
help bring them home so they're they're
in this situation they don't just want
revenge they have
actual people that they know their their
friends their relatives that are
actual slaves
and they can go help them and that's
what they're trying to do
[Applause]
you say this when you're when you're
talking to them but what i also had come
to learn about the yezidis was that when
i said isis had already taken away their
hopes and happiness
they would now allow them to take away
their sanity too the sun ladies were
strong always sitting upright
a few tears were shed but hastily wiped
away as the morning melted in the
afternoon
isis had abducted yazidi girls as young
as eight
trading them at the market for a few
dollars
i learned of one young mother who was
pregnant at the time of capture
she had given birth in the back room of
her overlord's home
but was not permitted to feed her
newborn son
the baby cried and cried the muslim
militant beheaded him
the depth of depravity was hard to
swallow
and we all sat and clouded quietude for
a small period
it's important to us to be able to
protect our dignity and honor a 19 year
old son lady named mesa finally said
softly shattering the wincing silence my
family is very proud
they encourage me to join i'm very proud
to protect my people
after all that has happened to us
yazidis
we are no longer afraid
and as brave and stoic as the sun ladies
seem to me there was one thing that did
frighten them
the notion that yazidi boys who had been
kidnapped from mount
sinjar and presumably drugged and
brainwashed by isis
were now fighting their mothers and
sisters under the black flag of isis
we now have terrorist yazidis something
that never used to be
so you know we hear about child soldiers
throughout history
but this idea of what which happened
where they would capture these yazidi
kids that are seven
eight nine ten years old and brainwash
them
and abuse them and turn them into
extremist isis terror kits
and that still is still really it's
still a really big problem for them um
even even i guess given the lack of
resources so a lot of the
the boys that are coming back are still
are still very radicalized in
in many ways and i remember being in a
refugee camp or a displacement camp
for yezidis once and hearing just
horrific story about how one of the
he must have been probably six six seven
years old
and he'd been rescued and brought back
and tried to behead his baby sister
zed is his name in the book
back to the book one blazing summer
afternoon i traveled the bumpy road a
couple hours
north to the office of kidnapped affairs
it was perhaps one of the saddest
structures i ever entered not because
the building itself painted a bright
sunny yellow
and standing indomitable in the middle
of a city sprawling
but rather because of what it
represented the office had been
established with support from the
krg prime minister after the isis
eruption of 2014 to
find to help find thousands that had
gone missing
i would visit that office many times in
the months to come and every time it
would get sadder
you're talking to one of the individuals
there zaina
zane explained that it was her neighbors
muslim families that had lived side by
side with for generations who ended up
turning on them
one morning she said our neighbors came
for us zaina who was
32 years old had spent more than a year
as an isis sex slave when isis came they
said they didn't want to fight us they
told us to give them their weapons our
weapons
she said telling me her story all over
again but
this time face to face where it felt
cruder and more inescapable
we gave them everything we had these
were our muslim neighbors
but so many of them had become isis and
we didn't know
zaina whip winced as she recollected the
day isis assaulted her village
at the foot of mount sinjar the elderly
who could not run fast or far enough
were similarly
executed men and women separated
with older men dragged off to mosques to
be killed
the females including girls as young as
eight were loaded onto cars
and trucks and bound for mosul
isis took me my sister my brother's wife
and my little sister for 13 days we were
put in a school
we didn't know what would happen there
were about 50 people
women and children squashed into a room
there was no water for us to wash
ourselves
the children were sick zaina had lied to
her captors telling them that she was
married hoping somehow it might spare
her from their evil intentions
that somehow it would save her from
getting robbed of the one thing she
could never get back
her captors however were undeterred she
and dozens of others were
taken to a heavily guarded building in
the isis-controlled
iraq city of talafar yazidi girls under
the age of 14 were whisked away and sold
at auctions
the remaining women were handed off to
isis fighters and told they were hence
for
forth their property
when a fighter grabbed zaina and carter
off to
into a dust storm fear paralyzed her
from head to doe
in its official propaganda materials
isis justified killing
raping and enslaving yazidis calling
them devil worshipers
and linking them to their mandate to
reinstitute
reinstitute reinstitute slavery
raping them those unbelievers have
become a core
tenant of their theology
zayn is angry impounders threw her into
a prison cell
days later she was transferred to
another facility in talifar and forced
to convert to islam under the threat of
death
zane had already witnessed a dozen
fellow yazidis being
executed in cold blood as punishment for
their escape attempts
she was not ready to die but she was not
ready to give up on finding her freedom
zaina and her another yazidi woman were
sent to live with a jihadist in the isis
stronghold of mosul
he took me to this place they were flats
small tourist flats
it was a tourist community
then he raped me
for the next five months zaina remained
inside mosul and was handed off to
another militant
who locked her in a small room this is
how the game was played
rape had always been a weapon of war
that thrived on silence but the yazidi
community was bravely and gradually
changing that notion they were
collectively bucking the mortification
and the fright and all the repercussions
that came with it
to speak out and tell the world that
they would not be muted
it's a tough situation zaina admitted
with a shrug
but i am still here
and i mean i'm i'm skipping giant chunks
of the book as i'm going through with
different details and um
evil and i think
i write a fair bit in the book about
about sexual violence because i think
it's something that doesn't
it's very uncomfortable to talk about
and it's something that even now we're
seeing
isis fighters are not no isis fighters
are being held accountable
for for that and there's still this
mentality of
well these are terrorists you know
they're killing people so what do we
care about that for and i think
we we need to start shifting that
perspective they
they need to be trialed for those crimes
as as just as important
as every other horrific crime that
they've committed because that's
something that needs to change
and i think for so long i mean it and
they really officially became illegal in
you know to sexual violence in wartime
so it's something it's still relatively
new
and i think there's a lot of work that
needs to be done in that topic in you
know within the international community
that needs to be looked at and how can
that be sort of brought to justice
otherwise you do have that impunity
that's going to continue
and what so many of these women go
through have gone through in so many
different conflicts i think it really
deserves
a lot more attention than what it gets
but it's uncomfortable
it's uncomfortable to talk about fast
forward a little bit here to fallujah
uh the city is damaged but nothing like
the other cities where isis has been
dislodged explained in iraqi i tell
intelligence officials who work closely
on the fallujah campaign
this was a well-planed operation led by
iraq's
golden division the golden division was
iraq's special for
special operations forces it ultimately
had been created
by u.s led coalition forces after the
2003 invasion
and had received top-notch training
this is a local talking about the
the push through the city and he said if
the decision was mine
i would have made a statue for every
fighter in the battle against terrorism
those heroes are examples of courage
when when
faced with daesh
it was awesome for me it's awesome it
was awesome for me to watch as all this
stuff was taking place
um you know obviously i retired in 2010
but
when we worked with the iraqis a lot of
times the iraqi soldiers they weren't
very determined
and it was you know they would they
would
have a lot of hard times sticking to the
fight
and we had an entire battalion one time
leave the battlefield and so that was
not a great that's not a great
look right and so when
i started getting reports back from my
friends that were in missoula with the
iraqis and the iraqis
were fighting they were fighting and not
just in missoula but in ramadi in
fallujah
the iraqis were fighting and it was
it was so that's kind of why i mentioned
that because i i had worked with
some of the troops that trained up the
iraqi special forces the iraqi special
special operations forces and they did
take the lead
and it was awesome to see their
courage and that they were going in they
were fighting they took massive
casualties in mosul they took
massive casualties my friend told me
that
in the first few days they thought to
themselves we not
the iraqis might run out of troops
because they are taking so many
casualties
i can tell you when we were in ramadi in
they wouldn't have taken that many
casualties because they wouldn't have
continued to fight they would have run
away
and so here this they were fighting
for a cause that they believed in and it
was awesome to see that taking place
yeah and i really noticed also just in
between 2014
2019 just that that trajectory and how
much over that time
i guess that their will to win was
really compounded
um and yeah by the end of it i mean they
would
they've seen some of the most horrific
combat that you can begin to imagine i
mean
just the level of what they've
experienced
for those that have gotten through it is
really remarkable
oh you know i can't
there's some of these examples that you
give
of who this enemy was
i i just i just have to read them
every day for three months they tortured
me azir
from where he sat stranded on the syrian
side
of the shuttered turkish border but
after a while
the torture just became routine he was
one of the thousands of prisoners
arrested by isis for so-called crimes
like wearing western jeans or smoking a
cigarette
but he was also one of a select few who
had managed to claw their way out of the
terrorist group's dungeons
with all his limbs intact
short of jail liberated by opposing
forces such escapes were considered rare
just
another another one nazra another former
captive
isis told us we will give you safety if
you give up your weapons
but they lied to us they took our
weapons and they arrested us
many of nasra's fellow soldiers had had
since been executed
but many remained incarcerated there was
no rights or to attorneys due process
trials or even a phone call
he estimated that as many as 2 000 iraqi
armored soldiers had been slain
since succumbing to isis over the past
two years he also estimated that 5000 at
that time remained in prison bowels
across the country
the cages were so small nazra said that
their torsos were marked by the folds of
skin
and their limbs tinged blue from the
hours of crouching
curled like a fetus in the womb
women arrested by isis typically
disappeared behind the prison's exterior
held
separately from the men and were often
never seen again
children are not exempt from the torment
either a large number of children have
been arrested by isis
my friend hassam a member of the syrian
activist group
raqqa is being slaughtered silently he
explained
the most common charges are insulting
allah and cooperating with apostates
they are being tortured just like men
and some of them have died under torture
they torture children too mostly
flogging beating on the hands and feet
and psychological torture i was
administered with electric shocks my
bones were broken i was hung by my feet
from the ceiling and beaten with my
hands tied behind my back said ali
a professional in his mid-40s who had
been arrested in the early days of the
terrorist onslaught
on suspicion of being an atheist
they swore on a quran that i would be
cut to pieces
you make a note here you can take a life
without killing
that's what torture does
between the summers of 2015 and 2016
isis had been on an especially vicious
rampage to compensate for the loss of
seasoned soldiers
and to take into drugging those it
radicalized or first
forced into its lair isis is using
special tablets
the fighters take drugs and they don't
know where they are or what they are
doing
they are just shooting and fighting one
kurdish intelligence official explained
they lose their minds some can be shot
20 times before they go down
that ominous drug was known as captagon
is that right a methamphetamine-like
variant of the
banned pharmaceutical fentanyl fentanyl
phalene
it was manufactured in copious
quantities primarily in lebanon and
neighboring syria
where it was sold to isis through
middlemen
it removes any barriers you would have
the fighting
there is no second guessing they just go
out and kill
it's still a very common battlefield
drug often comes from lebanon or syria
and yeah it's unfortunately it's it goes
just beyond isis but
it's a very common it's becoming a very
common drug
that a lot of militias and even
government soldiers are sort of being
given to
to give them that sense of invincibility
to
have them go out there and and you know
do whatever they're told and and
i think yeah really it really gained
prominence under isis
um with little kids
yeah yep it's drugging them up
among the ranks of captured brainwashed
and drugs
drugged were scores of yazidi boys whose
minds had been twisted to turn against
their own people
they had been propelled into training
regimes that included islamist
indoctrination and weapons instruction
they had been forced into learning the
finer points of beheading
forced into becoming suicide bombers and
into serving
as human shields
did your perception
of evil
change while you were there
i think in the beginning
i perhaps had a little bit more of a
black and white um
perspective on it which i think you know
especially in the us
we tend to sort of think which i think
is completely wrong but we tend to
always
it always comes down to a religion thing
and and
that always always is often painted as
the motivating factor
and i think what i really learned
from people that were joining isis it
was really one of
five things or one of you know ten
things that was motivating them to join
and so i think the complexities for me
really grew in that
because i suddenly started to see you
know when i isis is absolutely evil and
that
that hasn't changed for me but what i
started to see was the complexities of
how they got to that point and why they
joined and it wasn't so black and white
really
and that majority of them
really were joining more out of a
necessity for survival than it
necessarily was
um some kind of you know
religious extremism religious extremism
however there was a difference between
the ones that were coming foreigners
were coming
and they were often a lot more extreme
in that respect
what i found for the iraqis in
particular that were joining
um was that a lot of them it was you
know isis had come in and taken over
their
town or their village and you know they
still needed to feed their family
um so you know those kind of
complexities grew
for me in it was a lot harder to look at
things in
in such sort of black and white terms
yeah i think you're right that america
definitely misses the point on that a
lot
um it was always i still i still have
conversations with people
that will talk to me about
or they'll come at me about you know we
had no reason to be fighting the iraqis
and i was like
hey we were fighting alongside the
iraqis
they were literally going into the same
buildings with us that's what they
were doing that we were we weren't
fighting against the iraqis we were
fighting against the insurgents that
were there
same thing with the um what you
mentioned about
you know how are we gonna how am i gonna
feed my family there's
plenty of 14
17 19 22 year old young male
iraqis that wanted money and how are
they going to get money
well there's someone over here that's
going to pay them 50 to go shoot an rpg
at the coalition forces and that's what
they're going to do
and they weren't jihadists they were
little hoodlums
just like a little hoodlum in america
that's
how are you going to make them a living
in america in some crappy
city where you don't have any
opportunities oh i'm going to be a drug
dealer or i'm going to be a gang banger
because somebody's going to pay me
you know to go and carry this from here
to there it's it's an
economic decision more than anything
else and and
you know even when they're talking about
you know if it's a religious thing
well it can't be a religious thing
because we've got it's the actual
muslims fighting against the muslims
it's not like there's there's
it's not about that and what the other
crazy thing is you know when you
when you talk to people and you know
i would explain well you know we were
working with oftentimes a
majority shia army and it would be hard
for them to interact with the sunnis and
people have
no they don't understand what you're
talking about and that was a big
you know with isis is you know you
disbanded
an entire you know the sunnis were very
disbanded after saddam and yet they
still had their weapons and they're out
on the street and feeling
you know persecuted by by the government
and
so what are they going to do they're
going to band together it was the same
people it wasn't
it wasn't anything new i think isis was
sort of looked at as this
group that came out of nowhere and
dropped from the sky well no they
they were always there um they just kind
of came together
at some point when you mentioned
baghdadi
um abu bakr baghdadi al-baghdadi um
we my task unit
in ramadi in 2006 went to go and
capture or kill him he had a mission to
go capture kill him
and didn't get him it's actually the
it's actually the opening story
leif leif babin was the ground force
commander on that operation
they got into a big gunfight because
there was security there which means he
was probably in that vicinity
but you're right well it's not these
aren't they didn't drop from the sky
this was a guy that had been there and
fought as an insurgent
and was on the run and constantly trying
to maneuver
and so yeah these people didn't drop
from the sky
and you know the other crazy thing
that you can compare to a lot of bad
situations in the world where
what they want is there to be problems
what the what the insurgents want is to
create
division right division and they would
go and bomb
shia mosques just to get the shias to
lash out at the sunnis and then the
sunnis
they were trying to create a civil war
and it was
very very hard to walk that line and
make sure that you're
doing this in a proper way and even when
we in ramadi
when we got there in 2006 i thought we
were just going to do a big sweep
through like we did
like like the marines did in fallujah
just go and rubble every building
and just run through it
and maliki the prime minister who was a
shia
knew that if he did that it would be bad
it would be bad and so he said no we're
not going to do that we're going to do
it in a more
sparing way as with minimal force
required and that's what we did there
was still force required but it was
a lot less kinetic than fallujah was
so yeah i'll tell you
but um all that being said i i
the the the evil that's perpetrated is
just absolutely horrific and you capture
it in this book and
what scares me the most about it
is how easily people are swayed towards
it doesn't take much to push somebody
over the line from being a normal person
to beheading children
which is which is horrific
and you know i i did one podcast on the
on the milai massacre
there was roughly 500 old men
women and children no military age males
there at all
500 murdered raped
mutilated and the reading the interviews
with the guys that perpetrated this
and you read their backgrounds and you
read where they came from and you read
what they did
you can't it's we have to be on the
lookout for this kind of stuff
because these guys committed heinous
atrocities
equivalent of isis atrocities and they
were
americans that had crossed over the line
absolutely and i really think you know
and this is something i found in
afghanistan
in in syria and iraq and a lot of other
places that
we when i say we we just don't give
enough attention to and that is
government corruption and how much of
these things are a symptom
of that you know if you have to pay
someone every time you're going to go
through a checkpoint
you know so that some policeman can line
his pocket if you have to
if you see your leaders rolling around
with you know the
in these fancy cars and big houses and
rolexes and and
and you're not you know you can't get by
you're sweeping in the street and still
not getting
any services then at some point it's
going to make you angry and when you're
angry enough i also think it's a big
factor
for for joining a lot of these groups to
sort of rise up against their own
governments
and i think it's something that
when i talk to officials about it
they're often so quick to throw up their
hands
we can't do anything about that that's
just a systemic problem
okay but you're always going to be
dealing with terrorism as a
systemic problem from that problem
because
corruption is just such a huge driver of
it in
every way shape or form and i just think
it's something that gets barely any
attention
when it's such a big reason
why these groups exist and continue to
exist and will continue to exist
yeah you have that um you have that
little bit of anger in the back your
mind that you're being oppressed
and then someone comes along and says
hey you can fight that oppression with
us
and i'm in let's do this no
fast forward a little bit what does war
look like
it isn't just blister buildings and
empty brass casings and displacement
camps
war looks like wounds and soldiers who
don't resemble fierce fighters but are
men
in unfathomable pain
soldiers belong to someone they are
mother's child
someone created them and brought them
into the world only for the world to rip
them apart
and for what was it worth it it was
always the question in my mind
but ever the hardest to ask
soldiers in medical staff you go into a
into a hospital
soldier and medical staff faced a fight
of a different kind
no money and no medicine to treat almost
9 500 that have been seriously wounded
the tiny hospital if one could even call
it that had no mri equipment or ct
scanners it reminded me of poor clinics
of a soviet time and place
there were thousands of open unresolved
case files several soldiers young faces
old faces
and with body parts gone gone came
forward to outline their predicaments in
pain
to reconstruct the blows to their bodies
i feverishly jotted down all i could in
my fraying notebook
and and you go through just talking to
soldiers and
their their horrific wounds that they're
you know um
pawan ishmael been defusing a roadside
bomb for peshmerga on christmas eve in
2014 when it exploded his two comrades
died much of his body was burned and his
thigh skin had been reduced to ash
karwan saeed 37 years old
proudly dressed in his soldier's uniform
he was one of the victims of the
isis chemical attack
kiter merker 42 years old 25 year old
peshmerga serviceman
ambushed by an isis vehicle
around from a pkm machine gun cleaved
below his left ear
and lodged a few millimeters from the
top disc in his back
the round remained there infected and
inflamed his hands were numb
his head ached persistently
bizarre hussein 32 year old
been working on the front lines
struck by a sniper's bullet in broad
daylight reduced from a strong
able-bodied man to an almost infantile
physical and mental state hussein could
no longer control his legs nor could he
control his head
and eye movements occasionally he could
speak slowly
other times his eyes just swelled with
confused tears
as the words would not come out
these men had been robbed of bones and
body parts that could not grow back some
had lost their minds
but none had lost their self-respect
they were heroes who did not look like
conventional heroes but constituted what
the hollywood depiction
of heroes should have been
and once again to your earlier point
holly of
when you read 40 were wounded or 12 were
wounded or
seven were wounded or a thousand were
wounded
the way you d and i just breezed through
those i didn't go into the detail that
you go into
some of the back story but every one of
those little statistics is a person
going back to tal afar
this is a here's a tactic when the
people came
when the people from town heard that
kirkuk had been taken over by isis
many came out to the streets to
celebrate so this is what we're talking
about
you've got people that you've got the
shia
power and you've got isis taking over
kirkuk and now the sunnis come out so
yeah let's celebrate
and then what happens with all the
families out in the street isis members
then executed their scheme and had the
trucks ready and filled them with young
boys
and imported them to the front lines
isis has used all sorts of tactics and
human shields many times before
isis was using the young boys for three
main functions
functions on their fateful front line as
direct fighters as human shields
and as suicide bombers
one soldier showed me a video of the
remnants of a cauterized truck
and told me the three inside were just
kids taken from the talifar
streets just a day earlier
what is war war is the reason you wake
up there is no life outside of the
conflict
you eat and breathe when you're in it it
is impossible to have a life outside or
even to if you attempt
the ritualistic movements of daily life
the soldiers i met may have had their
families but war always came first
it was not a choice they had no option
but to live it and breathe it
they had all abandoned their studies and
or deserted their livestock or quit
their jobs to defend their people
for a paltry paycheck a paycheck that
often did not come on time if at all
there is no time for anything but war
how often are you going in and out of
country during this time
um i lost count of the amount of trips
would you would you normally stay for a
month yeah it varied some points
some points you know i'd go in and do a
trip for a few weeks
other points i would go in and end up
doing a trip for a few months i just i
often left it very open-ended depending
on getting what i needed
so yeah it was sort of a lot of going in
and out and then i'd go to other
countries in between it all
so i was going to cover other conflicts
kind of at the same time and then i
would just go back or i'd spend a chunk
of time
you know back in the us and and then go
back and spend a chunk of time it was
sort of just
whatever i could get that i felt i
needed to
to go back for and then it was all just
very um
it's a very arbitrary step to how long i
thought i needed to be there for
is there any dry is there any
of your work driving this is there
stories that you owe or anything like
that nothing
you know no nothing sort of pragmatic in
that sense it was more
um yeah it was more just trying to to
develop it as it as it needed to be i
guess
in that very organic sense we've talked
about
the sun ladies we've talked about some i
think we've talked about some of the
other peshmerga females
there are females on the other side as
well
females of the caliphate
i got 15 years one plump
54 year old woman said flopping onto the
office couch
for being an isis terrorist i wanted to
be a suicide bomber
you you refer to this female as ks chaos
wanted to tell her story in a jagged
timeline a biography bound by
battles she was the daughter of an arab
father and a kurdish mother
she grew up speaking her grandfather's
language language of turkmen
she ended up in isis after her marriage
fell apart
i wanted a divorce i was very poor i
have schizophrenia
and was just diagnosed with blood cancer
and my only daughter wasn't treating me
well
i was borrowing money from people for
the treatment ks lamented eyes welling
but then i grew desperate in the obscure
days after mosul i was
snatched after mosul was snatched by
isis in june of 2014
when the terrorist group was quickly
capturing territory across iraq
she had detailed her situation to a cab
driver named mahmoud
in her home city of kirkuk he offered
her a solution
he was isis and said if i joined they
would treat me well
and pay me i said i would
join on one condition that they make me
a suicide bomber and get me out of my
misery
the only thing i was seeking was to be
bombed and die
so again you are pointing out
who becomes isis and why and there you
go here you have someone that's
schizophrenic has all these problems in
their life
and and you know you see the same thing
in cults in america right you take
someone that's been abused you take
someone that's down on their luck
and that's that's who cults actually go
after they go after people like that for
the most part
and this is a classic situation
psychological issues
divorced uh
being treated bad by her daughter
there you go um yeah and she you know in
the
when i was sitting with her and she's
sort of vacillating between this
laughing and crying and it was all
it was all very bizarre but i i talked
in length
with one of the the guards that was in
the room at the time when she was
telling me her story
and you know did she's sort of painting
herself to be this very innocent person
but
there's two sides to the story and the
other side being that
she was was really evil and she was one
of the people that was
was taking these yazidi women and and
helping facilitate them to be sold and
and beating them and things so you know
it's a very complicated situation in
that
colonel marwan sabri of the yazidi
peshmerga battalion recalled that in
march 2017 a disillusioned
american i'm moving from females this is
to westerners
amongst the ranks
a disillusioned american surrendered
himself to the peshmerga
he had begged them not to shoot him that
fighter turned out to be 26 year old
mohammed jamal khawise from virginia
who was later deported to virginia's
eastern district for indictment
a 20 year old 20-year jail sentence
handed down
october 2017 awaited him
and you go through some of these other
westerners
males females coming in from first world
countries
coming in from america coming in from
parts of europe to go
giving up it's crazy crazy
yeah their their recruitment campaign
for for foreigners was
was pretty extensive
um moving forward into the book all
tools
in the war against isis had eventually
pointed to mosul
it was the isis bread and butter the
head of the snake
i learned that many mo mosul civilians
innocent souls who had managed to
survive over three years of isis
occupation
were slaughtered in retaliation as iraqi
forces surrounded the city
to have made it this far just to be
taken out in the twilight
of the fight jarred me their body parts
were strewn across
dusty streets tiny bodies cracked open
left to die
after their fleeing parents were gunned
down some hiding
underneath the bloody corpses of their
family members orphaned and forever
traumatized
i remembered the howls of a broken woman
her little daughter had been lost for
days
until she was found with nothing but a
gaping black hole
where the back of her head used to be
suicide belts are strapped onto helpless
civilians including women and children
by isis
kareem of the iraqi counterterrorism
forces
conjectured this was a big dilemma we
didn't know who a bomber was
and who was not many of our men died
from these people
forced to be bombers
this is one of the things that when my
friends were over there
and they were reporting back they'd have
these kids
women children men coming to checkpoints
with strapped with bombs and
the predicament that they were in but
then also the great lengths
that these that the americans made to
try and
spare the law because what you normally
do with a
suit well obviously a suicide bomber
what do you do you could kill them
and what do you do with a roadside bomb
or an ied you blow it you what we do
we call it blowing in place so you just
go put a explosive charge near it and
you blow it up and then it's safe
what you don't want to have to do you do
have to do it sometimes but you don't
have to go up there with a
whatever like a like a an action movie
with a pair of pliers and the wire
cutters and
actually disarm that thing because it's
dangerous and by the way
the way they build those bombs
oftentimes when you cut one wire
it's rigged to blow up and that somehow
causes a detonation anyways so what they
had in many of these cases were these
kids
or innocent people that had these bombs
strapped and could go walk into the
checkpoint
it certainly complicates and it's
there's no easy solution to that
yeah you know we we talked about on a
few podcasts ago we talked about the
idea of total war
which is at the far extreme of conflict
right
total war we will do absolutely and act
you asked me echo charles you asked me
give me any like is there any examples
of total war and i said
isis they did there was no boundaries
zero boundaries to what they would do i
mean america
pretty much always operates in some
there's some cap now you could say world
war ii
once we dropped the atomic bombs it was
like hey this is total war and we are
going to do whatever it takes to win
as quickly as possible that's that's how
you can make a decision to say hey we're
going to drop
these atomic weapons
but other than that you know there's
always
rules of engagement there's always
geneva convention there's all these
constraints but if you want to talk
about just
total war we will do absolutely anything
to and stoop to any level
of barbarity to try and achieve victory
this is an example
female isis members were said to have
stooped to weaponizing their own babies
seemingly harmless mothers carrying
their babies had been trained to enter
areas thick with iraqi soldiers only to
blow themselves up
their young and their liberties
liberators around them
to bits
an enemy is most dangerous when on the
defensive or when they are fighting for
survival
this was not an easy fight and isis was
not the jv team
isis did not care for rules of
engagement by which the west was taught
to fight
isis did whatever it would take to
achieve its strategic objectives
regardless of the consequences there you
go you and me
on the same page
president trump gave a free hand to his
then defense secretary mattis
who in may stressed military commanders
were no longer slowed by washington
decision cycles
or by the white house micromanaging that
existed
with president obama as a result of the
new approach
the fall of isis in iraq at least in
terms of territory
came even more swiftly than hardened u.s
military leaders expected
it moved more quickly than at least
i had anticipated brigadier general
croft said we and the iraqi security
forces were able to hunt down and target
isis leadership
target their command and control
so i kind of heard that a lot from the
leadership when i was
uh interviewing them i think that was in
the end of 2017.
and that was sort of the the reoccurring
theme was that they were given a
more of a free hand and they were sort
of able to push forward
i could look at that you know in
hindsight in many different ways and
and you know how that
could be interpreted but you know that
was the narrative on the ground at the
end of 2017 was that they felt that they
were
given more support than they had been in
the past
yeah i think that and it's also very
interesting when you look at the fact
that
this is this is general mattis right
this is general mattis
who's saying this and obviously general
mattis and
and president trump in the end were not
friendly right which it shows you how
very caustic trump's leadership could be
or could become
if you you know crossed him yeah um
and it didn't start out that way clearly
you know at some point they they
were seeing right away it's it's
what i love about this and what i what i
is this is decentralized command this is
saying okay listen
i'm the president there's bad guys there
i don't care what you do
what i want them i want them gone i want
this that problem solved
commander's on the ground okay we're
gonna go solve it yeah that's what i
said go solve it
that's that's a great sign right that's
a great sign
uh and obviously i guess the disease of
victory as general patton used to call
it
meaning hey i i we won this thing now
everyone should just listen to me more i
mean that's
that's what you have to watch out for
you can't let your ego
make you think that just because you
made one good decision
you're gonna make all good decisions
doesn't work that way but this is just
um
again very revealing
of how confusing donald trump's
leadership
could be that you could have
that he could have completely empowered
general mattis to go and solve this
problem
and then a couple years later general
mattis
leaves yeah and i think it really
started that way you know with iraq with
afghanistan go do what the job needs
to be done and and my understanding from
from talking to different people at the
white house at the time was that
president trump knew he's he's not you
know he is the commander of chief but
was the commander-in-chief but isn't a
military guy so he kind of
he he gave that job to the generals to
do and then at some point i
i feel like that shifted and the love
that he sort of had for
the the men then somehow sort of changed
i'm not entirely privy to what happened
there but there was definitely a shift
at some point
yeah it was all very strange to watch
from the outside
um general mcmasters another guy that
was on his staff who
is from everything i understand i've
never met with him i've never we've
covered some of his stuff on
on this podcast because he's
very res from everything i've understood
he's one of the most respected guys
he worked up in tallafar my brigade
commander
when i was in ramadi had relieved him in
talifar he had done an amazing job in
talafar
bringing stability to that city we used
that plan
in ramadi so so mcmaster's just a
very well respected and he he was gone
general kelly same thing i mean just
a marines marine
whose son was killed in afghanistan
and he ends up so so you're sitting
there it causes a lot it's very it makes
it
it's obvious that it's very hard to
logically track the thought patterns
of president trump you you can't really
just
there's some inconsistency there that
you just it's just confusing
but at this time it was very clear this
is another great
another thing that is very positive it
says here we
we really had one mandate and that was
tenable
for iraqi security forces to defeat isis
militarily
here in alambar i feel we have achieved
that mission
folsom said i never felt constrained in
a lot of ways i felt
liberated because we had a clear mandate
and there was no questioning that
we were able to focus on what our job
was without distraction
and i think that goes a long way in what
we were trying to accomplish
so that's another thing it was a very
clear mission
and and i'm sure general mattis
drove a lot of that to say okay what do
you want us
what what is it you want us to do
because if you don't have a clear
mission
well i mean i don't do i need to say
anything else if you don't have a clear
mission what are you trying to do
yeah and that that mission was defeat
isis and and
it became very complicated i think
because everybody wanted to
argue what does defeat isis mean or
people thought well
if we don't if we if we leave syria then
that leaves it open to
you know all sorts of other things but
in trump's mind
i think it was clear it was defeat isis
militarily at least
not defeat the ideology of isis i think
that's going into a
whole different rabbit hole but in terms
of territory
arguably yes that that that was
something that was achieved
oh yeah yeah and killed a lot of them
tens of thousands of isis fighters were
killed
i'm going to fast forward a little bit
you
you you talk from every like i said your
your effort to
capture many different perspectives and
one of the one perspectives that you
capture in here is of the iraqi
christians
and i had to read this part because just
because it's very moving
scores of iraqi christians in the region
who earlier fled
in fear neighboring countries such as
jordan lebanon turkey weren't much
better off
father afrom said am i saying that name
right afrom
they had waited years for visas to
western
nations only to be rejected now the
refugees were stranded
did not have money or the courage to
resettle in other pockets of iraq those
fortunate enough to have been
granted visas had to watch their
families be split apart
some members lived in the u.s others in
europe and still others were strewn
across the middle east
what was what is war it was options
almost all bad
does war ever bring about options that
could be considered good
that sense of helplessness
hung in the air during sunday's service
women in aphotic mantillas
sang and prayed and the men stuck struck
candles to illume the darkened space
while tiny children played outside
in the cold sunshine
destroyed all the crosses crosses that
had been made 150 years ago
father ephraim said but i said to my
people
make new crosses
you you note in here again
you have you have a couple modes and i'd
say ten percent of the book is
sort of history slash uh
facts to give context around one of the
one of the
history lessons that you give us is that
in 2003 as the americans
invaded for the first time into iraq
there's 1.5 million christians
and in 2019 there's 200 000 christians
in iraq
yeah and there's two sort of very
different schools of thought i think in
that is that
one being a lot more effort should be
made to ensuring that they do stay
you know that's the land that's that's
that's their homeland
iraq essentially so that
or the second thought being they're
going to continue to be persecuted
regardless of
whether it's isis whether it's
government whether it's an al-qaeda
irrespective of
that their lives are in danger so
everything needs to be done to sort of
bring them out and and have them
resettle in europe or the united states
so there's two very
it causes quite a schism i think in that
community because there's just two very
divergent thoughts on what the
the better alternative to that is help
them stay or help them leave
a whole section here isis wives
infighting jealousy and regrets
and this is where you know you started i
didn't dive too much into it
you said you were talking about the the
recruitment system that they had in
europe and i kind of moved past it
i didn't mean to like ignore that but
it's just that you address it a little
bit more here
lena frizzler was a 28 year old blue
eyed
blonde with milky pale skin from hamburg
germany
she was once an aspiring business
student with european dream of money
travel
family and success in 2012 she married
converted to islam
and left the country comforts of her
home for turkey she said that she had
made the abrupt decision
after being courted and encouraged by a
known radical salafist
in the hamburg area she called him
pierre vogel
who urged others to rise up and fight
against the bashar al-assad syrian
regime
her husband also came under pierre's
spell
one day my husband came home and told me
he wants to go to syria and fight
lina told me matter of factly as she
nursed her one year's old son
her second child with an isis fighter
and that goes back to what i said
earlier with the government the
corruption how much of this is a symptom
of
of that bigger problem that we tend to
ignore and that's what i found a lot
with the
these women and these fighters that
especially the foreigners
yes some were going very specifically to
join isis but there was this sort of
whole
group that went before isis was even a
thing
and their mandate was to go and fight
bashar
and so i think that sort of we we tend
to sort of
overlook uh how much of a symptom
you know it is of a government problem
another german native a stunning
raven-haired 26 year old named
heidi ralphie told me she spent most of
her days alone in a tent
she said she had fallen in love with an
older boy in 2009
then then several years in a
relationship he informed her that he was
going to help the people of syria that
were suffering as a result of the war
and bashar al-assad love struck heidi
ditched her
social network her social work studies
for a life
of a jihadi wife in 2014.
her beloved kareem later died on the
battlefield she remarried
here's the remarrying it was an easy
process there was just there was an isis
man
we all knew with a laptop and he would
just ask us what we wanted and bring us
guys to choose
i met three but chose a man from kosovo
blinded by shrapnel because he wanted to
go to turkey for an operation
that was my out so she was trying to get
out now
she never made it across the border
months dragged dragged on she wanted to
return home to germany i was in love it
was a mistake
and often these women when they try to
get out they'd get money someone from
home would send the money
and they'd pay you know what they called
a smuggler or whatever to get them out
and the smuggler would just take the
money and drive them round and round and
round in a few circles and drop them
back
so it sort of became this you know um
hotel california you go in but you can
and you can never leave so that was sort
of the recurring theme with the women
i found too that even if they wanted to
it would they couldn't
ahmed a 43 year old
departed karachi pakistan with her
husband and children to fight for the
syrian people
my husband was distraught after seeing a
unicef
documentary about the war in syria he
wanted to go fight bashar
my husband sold our house and all our
things
for us to leave he used to be a normal
man worked in telecommunications
but he saw that documentary and he made
it
mind change
and like you know like we like you've
been saying that's um
what kind of underlying issues were in
his head
right what was going on could he not get
ahead at work
you know could he was he not getting the
support that he needed what was going on
you have to add in all these other
factors
another one um
this is a this is a a male born to
moroccan parents in the idyllic
countryside just outside of brussels
hamza
was well known in his community revered
for his soccer and boxing skills his
last job was with dhl
delivery service homs admitted that in
2011 he came
became more militant in his
ideological views after being introduced
to a salafist
group called sharia for belgium
the group called for the overthrow of
democracy and urged young people to join
isis abroad almost two years after he
had heeded the call
and set out for the battlefield the
organization would be formally
designated as a terrorist group by the
belgian state
hamza was first placed at an immigrant's
location in the opposition
bastion of idlib where he
was housed alongside several western
fighters after two weeks he spent
he was sent for 40 days of training
weapons fitness religious doctrine
after that he was deployed to the
northern city syrian city of
aleppo to fight i just want to give
people some kind of a
indication
hamza particularly remembered the isis
celebrations after the 2014 beheading of
american journalist
james foley and how leaders used the
gruesome event as motivation
it was to say look how we are fighting
the americans
he continued underscoring that isis
initially gained momentum
after the formation of a coalition of
over 60 allied nations designated to
defeat them
designed to defeat them the coalition's
creation was spun by the isis propaganda
machine to show how strong the militant
group was against such a massive force
homs repeatedly emphasized in the
interview that the ideology driving isis
was not going to stop and had permeated
some circles so profoundly
that it would be next to impossible to
defeat
he also said each new incarnation of the
group brought a school of thought
even more rigid than its predecessor
a central tenet of isis brainwashing of
new followers
was its singular focus on the united
states
hamza said in what he described as an
obsession
with america it was the big enemy
gotta have somebody to fight against
absolutely gotta have a bad guy
we're the good guys you gotta have a bad
guy
america makes a very nice bad guy for
much of the world yeah and there's
always gonna be a different cause you
know
that's what i always found too is that
you could i'll use example of of
guantanamo bay so
you could close that down but they're
going to find another cause so there's
always going to be a cause there's
always going to be a reason
um and so i think we think
we you close one thing down you you um
you create a palestinian state whatever
the reason is there's always going to be
another one
and that's something that i think people
don't really want to recognize
also when it comes to policy is that you
can't have these arbitrary lines between
war and peace necessarily i mean that
those days are long gone
with terrorist groups like this it's
just something that
i think we have to learn to manage to
some degree and i hate saying that
because i want to be able to say that
it can be totally defeated but i don't
think that's realistic
i think
maybe i hope
maybe i just hope but i i i
always hope that
human beings intrinsic
motivation for freedom
will rise eventually
to a very positive place in the world
i hope so too i really do uh
i'm not even sure i believe my own hope
that's what my hope is though i said i
hope yeah
um i think and and what's unfortunate is
you know you see
various places in the world where
freedom
rises and that my
theory right would be that once it rises
it's going to move forward right
and unfortunately we see it received i
mean iran's a great example right i mean
right
the freedom in iran in the
60s and 70s was completely on the rise
and it absolutely receded totally
so maybe maybe my hope is misplaced
you know i think in sirius who you in
the beginning
with the revolution the arab spring you
there were freedom fight
you know they were it was a legitimate
sort of movement of wanting a better
life that wasn't
under the the bashar al-assad
dictatorship
but what happened was it got hijacked by
a lot of of these terrorist groups and
jihadists who then
i guess diluted that opposition and then
it became this very again it wasn't
black and white it was an incredibly
complicated
mixture of of opposition with
a lot of them being good solid you know
wanting to live a better life and then a
lot of them being these
awful terrorists so you know
that that itself was something i think
was was really hijacked and deluded
yeah that story and you do a very good
job in this of
kind of showing some of those strange
alliances
very strange alliances that took place
and
what do you make of those strange
alliances who are you aligned with and
and wait a second what happens when
we're done with this job and all of a
sudden i look my person that just helped
me and
realized that they've got a whole nother
idea where they're heading
i mean iran worked to defeat isis too
and look at
well you know how the u.s policy is with
iran i mean
the friend of your friend is not your is
your enemy or
or not yeah exactly that's the thing is
that that old saying
is the thing that that saying just goes
around in circles
yeah yeah you know i'm gonna i'm gonna
fast forward past
some of this some of these horrors i'm
gonna i'm gonna pass the
pass the battle you know you you detail
some of the stuff of mosul
and you definitely talk about raqqa
and in syria and i'm gonna fast forward
and again i'm just gonna i have to
otherwise i just sit here and read this
entire book
and i don't want to have you here
forever
but we get to a point where the cleanup
is now happening and this is
at the end of the book and the cleanup
is happening in missoula
and and in this particular case there's
cleanup happening in
in talafar
and i'll just go to the book 40 miles
west of missoula
talafar had a population of about a
hundred thousand before being captured
by isis in june of 2014. the city was
liberated in october of 2017.
remnants of war were everywhere bodies
found around and under homes i learned
were not uncommon neither was the smell
of putrefied flesh
in many cases families living under isis
rule were for
forced to bury bodies in their own homes
and backyards
as well as in local public squares
sometimes victims were made to dig
their own shallow graves
the 43-person emergency division was
tasked only with removing civilian
remains from mass graves the larger
700 person nivena civil defense corps
was in charge of sweeping up bodies from
the streets
and collecting them from individuals
from individual from within
individual homes
the first wasted life to be
wretched up from the sewage was that of
an iraqi soldier
his bones a blood drenched uniform and a
pair of handcuffs
were exhumed
then came seven more all dragged from
beneath a home that had once served
as a local headquarters of isis
local officials who had been tipped off
to the presence of the remains just a
couple days earlier said the victims
were likely held in the basement
across the street at a second location
another
12 decomposed civilian bodies were
exhumed
among the remains found were those of at
least two children
and dismembered heads without bodies
each skeleton bore a thick black
blindfold most of the victims appeared
to have been slain
execution styles bullets showered into
the backs of their heads
it was a massacre more and more of the
same
one police official told me
a police official always accompanied the
recovery
workers through their day's work a
standard practice
it's never-ending the official continued
staring out
the yellow fog which lifted into the
bright sunshine as the day passed on
officials had become all too familiar
with the discovery of isis victims
our duty is to the innocent people under
the rubble
said hamadi al-hussein commander of the
civil defense corps
emergency convoy unit he explained to me
over
cold tea the night before isis kills
them
and throws them into the sewage one by
one and covers it over with cement
this is their way
after several grueling hours with small
children
watching from low-lying roof tops above
20 body bags were sealed
and handed over to iraqi federal police
law enforcement took them to a
specialized committee for examining the
bodies
whenever possible surviving family
members
of the victims were notified
a 44 year old rescue worker from mosul
considered something of a hero among his
peers for excavating the bodies
for 27 years it was a job that never got
easier
sometimes it's five or six entire
families all buried in one house
he told me after losing after hosing
himself off behind the fire truck
at the end of the shift in tallafar
as a father especially when i see women
and children
it hurts i've had to pull out many
pregnant women too
darude said he and his team had
recovered
2 400 bodies since mosul was liberated
last july
with more than two thousand of those
coming from the old city on the west
side
in talafar they'd recovered 640 bodies
many of whom were still unidentified
another 500 bodies were discovered last
year in a mass grave between the two
[Music]
strongholds
it wasn't just human recovery required
of the dedicated team ali was also
burdened with demining bodies
sometimes those of isis fighters i can
tell straight away if they are
isis they are usually booby-trapped and
often have foreign passports strapped to
them
we don't remove them our command after
demining them is to leave them
and authorities take those
i stood alone as the last of the lives
were swathed in those big black bags
their brains bursting through empty eye
sockets
i tore off my surgical mask heaving at
the smell of rotting corpses
in the unbearable heat
iraq stood still at the fork between a
potential future of death
and one that would value life
it was a place that resembled a
fractured mosaic that could only be put
back together by a young generation who
knew little of life
not maimed by the brutality
there was supposed to be a time after
the war
it was supposed to be a time of peace
only all it felt like was strange and
sorrowful
i thought about that tried and true
expression we all tend to offer one
another during hardships
everything happens for a reason
no
there was no reason these young men and
women had to die alone
their bodies left to de decay in the
literal bowels of their country
there was no great lesson to come from
that no sense
in that they had completed their mission
on earth
and no reason that it was their time to
be taken by god
that is the lie we tell ourselves
a child from the neighborhood who had
watched without
flinching as the bodies were brought up
peered over what was left of the bond
out fence
he looked through the gaping hole into
my tearful eyes
soon we stopped crying for the dead he
whispered
but all we can do is cry for the living
that too was war
and that is um it's not quite the
closing of the book but
obviously it's the it's the name of the
book
and like i said we probably covered five
i probably read
less than five percent of the book today
and these stories i mean every page
every story
just captures so much of this
perspective that you are
trying to convey
for me you know coming coming home from
my experiences
uh for instance my first deployment to
iraq we spent a lot of time in humvees
we were driving a lot we were
at that time the enemy would attack from
bridges
so when you drive underneath a bridge
you'd sort of get like a little
you kind of go into a little bit of a
standby mode
get that little that little um
heightened awareness right so when i got
back to america you're driving
and as you know around baghdad and much
of iraq
they look like highways in california
you know this is a big highway with
signs and it there was
you know when i first got back you'd
start to feel or a vehicle would get
close because you didn't want vehicles
close to your humvee convoy so
you'd see a vehicle coming close and for
that split second you'd think
why is this guy getting close to me or
you be approaching that bridge and get
that
little sensation of brace for it
so you have these memories i guess that
stick with you and i've got a bunch of
those different memories that stick with
me
what where are you at what memories
stick with you
do you have trouble getting back to
normal do you have
trouble with
going to sleep at night i think
you know this this was a project i
worked on a few years ago and i think
there has been a little bit of distance
from it for me
i remember being in the middle of it and
sort of um
you know when i was still writing and
covering it it was just it was it was an
you know obsession to try to understand
it to get the story right to get
the facts right and it was so
all-encompassing
and coming back it you know it always
took me a couple of weeks to kind of
readjust but
one of the biggest sort of long-lasting
i guess impacts i always found what
you know in my experience was i think it
was a sense of that
uh feeling a little bit unsafe but i
would be in new york or l.a
i was living in both cities at the time
and
you get a phishing scam or something on
your phone that everybody gets
and for me it was oh my god i'm being
targeted who wants something from me and
i always
i couldn't separate um you know and
think of it as well everybody gets these
for me it just became this sort of i was
convinced everybody was tapping into my
phone or
um and for me it was more of the i
couldn't see
this sort of enemy you know and that
took me a while to kind of let go of
that a little bit and to be like
you know you're okay nobody's nobody's
coming at you now
nobody's trying to hack into your emails
nobody's trying to figure out who
you're talking to on this particular day
or maybe they were but
you know it definitely was something i'd
exaggerated i think in my head
so that's something i've had to have
separation from and i think
that um i've done that but
i still i think about it a lot i think
about
you know a lot of the people that i met
and think you know i try to find out
where they are what they're doing i
think today with all these you know
whatsapp signal
encrypted messaging you stay in contact
with these people a lot and that's
something that
previous journalists and different
generations didn't have
so today which is lovely you can still
sort of stay in contact with them and
their families
and then but it also is is that
you do sort of feel helpless because
there's not much you can do
and i dedicate this book to um it was a
family that i stayed within in syria and
they live in a place called gabani
and that was sort of one of the big isis
strongholds in the beginning and
you know they took me in and you create
these immediate bonds with people
because
you know they were my immediate sort of
family and they had two young sons and
uh muslim's wife parishion was pregnant
at the time and they said oh
when i left and we'd gone through all
these you know experiences and
and when i left they said oh well if
she's a
um if we have a daughter we're gonna
name her holly and i just sort of smiled
and i thought that was just really
endearing and lovely
sure enough a few months later i get a
message and a picture that she had a
girl and they named her holly's fault
the same as me
that was funny and i try to sort of
check in i can't even send them
a copy of the book i can't send them you
know anything
but i tried to check in you know with
them
and it was really sweet because they
said oh there's about five hollies in
kobani now
so it's kind of this funny little trend
and i was just so
i was so endeared by it and i think it's
those moments in life
where you create bonds with people and
they want nothing from you
they're not trying to get anything from
you they're not trying to
have their name in a newspaper they're
not trying to to do any
of that they just want to protect you
and it's such a rare thing
in this day and age to have those
relationships that
you know aren't transactional in some
way other than it just comes from a
place that is so
pure and i think that's also why i was
so attracted to the work because you're
really meeting people
in their most authentic state
and i think that's just a huge thing
i've tried to do in my in my life at
home
too is is to really weed out you know
what
what doesn't serve me as a human being
and and
look for those authentic relationships
and that's
one of the biggest takeaways for me in
working in those war zones
i remember when when i got back from my
last deployment and then i retired
and i you know would talk to guys and
see
stories about guys that would that guys
that were in vietnam war and they'd go
back to vietnam and then when i started
doing the podcast
we met guys that had gone back to
vietnam and i read more stories about
guys that are going back to vietnam and
then you know you can take it to the
the guys that were in world war ii that
would go back to the beaches of normandy
and and i remember thinking to myself
as far as going back to iraq especially
when i first got
home this is i don't want to go back
there
don't want to go back there no i'm never
going back there
only recently have i started to feel
think to myself you know it would be
kind of cool to go back and
walk those streets again
where are you at oh i was i was planning
to go back
just before uh covered lockdown i had a
visa to go
and then i was approached to even go i
think like uh in a couple of weeks to go
and
i had to sort of turn it down because
for different reasons but
oh yeah in a heartbeat i feel like iraq
is sort of just
a um yeah it's kind of a second home
really
you know it's been a little bit since
i've been there but i have i have
nothing but but sort of a desire to
still go there i don't um
i don't view it as a place that i i
never want to go again
yeah i'm slowly getting through that um
maybe because i don't have a lot of
things i don't really like
my memories of it a lot of them are
great memories that's what makes me
start
you know i used to say to the platoon
guys like you're going through things
while you're on deployment
and you're mad about this and you're mad
at that guy and you're mad at this other
guy
and i said you know what two weeks after
we get home you're gonna forget all
those bad stuff just remember the good
stuff
and sure enough as time goes by you just
remember the good stuff so i think i'm
getting there with uh
specifically with the city of ramadi and
it was really i mean obviously it was
heart-wrenching to see
that when when ramadi got taken over by
isis
and the the black flag of isis
flying over the government center which
i know so many people had fought so
hard to liberate that city and it was
doing so well
and then it got smashed by isis i
remember
there's pictures of after after the
iraqi
soldiers went back in they annihilated
ramadi they blew up so many buildings
there was a neighborhood called tamim
on in western western ramadi and they
i saw pictures of it it was just leveled
building after building after building
because they just
every building that they thought might
have a mine they blew it up and guess
what they thought about they all had
ieds so they blew them all up
but yeah i think you have a much better
relationship
with the land and the people
and the memories that i do right yeah
and for me it really is
it comes down to the people it does it's
it's the people who
who i mean what a privilege it is to
to for these people to just to trust you
enough with some of these stories to be
that vulnerable with somebody that they
don't know
you know at least initially and i just
think that's
that's something i i take as a as an
honor really to be able to
to be some kind of vessel in uh
in telling that for me you know i hate
to use the word voice when people say
the voice of the voiceless i
no they have a voice but but i think as
a journalist you you are some kind of
vessel that can can bring that back and
and tell that
and i can't do anything really beyond
that i think that was also something i
had to learn was that
you want to be able to think that a
story is going to make a difference it's
going to change so and so
you know some lawmakers mind somewhere
and something's going to happen
and you know 99.9 of the time doesn't
change anything but
doesn't make it any you know less
important to do
and b once you take that weight off your
shoulders
it's so much easier to do your job
because again it's that clear mandate
you know what it is that you're doing
and everything else after that is out of
your hands and and
not in the description
well that's a probably a great place to
wrap this up because what you've
absolutely done in this book is
you have told their stories and we will
pass these stories on to as many people
as as we can
and uh i think like hallie love said you
know you've
got what your talent is right you've got
your skill in life and heli love
can make videos and sing and and you've
got this ability to write
and share these stories and
that's what you've done so
echo you got anything no that's it
i know holly that we can find you
well the book will be up on the website
um
if you want to order the book on twitter
and
on instagram you are holly i.e is that a
weird spelling for hong kong
i guess it's it's slightly unusual
because my mom was having a moment
holly s mccann mckay
mckay on and on facebook there's no s
just holly mckay and you also have
hollymckay.com
yes so i'll put it up there yep so
people can go there and check out what
you're up to what's your next project
what are you going to do next so i'm
working on a few different things so i
have a couple of writing projects that i
am notting out the basis on it's a
it's going to be quite a journey and i'm
waiting for travel to open up but i'm
sort of looking a little bit more into
the survival aspect of it um so
yeah so that'll be interesting and i
am yeah just kind of focused on that for
now
and sort of doing a lot more um sort of
geopolitical stuff as well so it's
kind of branching out do you write do
you are you writing news
anymore on a regular basis i'm doing a
little bit here and there
um but i'm really focused on my more
long-term projects right now
kind of getting down a little bit more
to the nitty-gritty and the things that
i
i really see is important as opposed to
uh
the daily churn so i'm sort of taking a
bit of a leap
in that so it's nice how was the book
writing process did you like it
i you have always have a love hate with
it you know
um but most of the time i really love it
and i
i love being able to to
i hate being having to decipher my
handwriting out of a notebook
but beyond that i really love being able
to kind of
just sit and you sort of meditate on the
details and and i try to remember colors
and faces and places and
and all those things and and try to to
put it into words and so
it can be challenging definitely and it
can be definitely moments that i just
i don't want to get up and do it did you
take pictures i did i took a lot of
pictures
so we need to get those up on the
website i'll get you pictures of
whatever you need so a lot of these
these people they have uh they have uh
faces and
places and yeah the you wrote a novel
i did when i was young and what's up
with the novel where
i'm i'm sure it's it's somewhere in
australia probably in my dad's
[Music]
it was a it was a sort of a young teen
fiction novel
yeah we don't need to go into that
i love to write i was writing you know
that was one thing aside from
from my ballet from a young age i love
to tell those stories and always sort of
love to write and
make up weird and wonderful things and
yeah awesome
awesome um anything else do you got
anything else here
so i just yeah thank you for having me
here and you know it's obviously
these things don't happen in isolation
so i have
a wonderful family back home in
australia my parents have always been
amazing support
my sister and my nieces and and then my
i call in my american family which is
really my you know close-knit
group of friends that i have in in
different pockets of america that have
really been
such a backbone of support for me um i
had one good friend miley
cardenas who's a veteran and she came on
a few trips with me and was amazing and
another good friend of mine dennis
santiago who helped me with the editing
so
yeah they're really my family in the us
and then my my family in australia
well it's all come together for uh i
mean i think it's very clear that this
is a powerful book
and i i thank you for coming on here i
thank you for
letting uh jocko publishing put it out
along with uh along with d'angelo
publishing yeah our friend sequoia
so that's awesome and it's it's an honor
for me to be able to help get this book
out there to the world and get these
stories shared
thank you i appreciate it and
by look i i i hope i didn't come off as
um
crazy or arrogant or like a jerk when i
was talking about the fact that
you we we do some crazy stuff when we're
young
and there's a certain amount of being
naive
but i don't care how naive you are or
how naive you were
for you to go into these places to
capture these stories and i didn't
there's there's
plenty of stories in there where i know
from being in combat myself
how close you were to the front lines
how close you how much danger you were
in all the time so
thank you for writing the book but also
thank you for
your courage and your bravery to go out
there take these risks to capture these
stories
to capture the horrors of war
so that hopefully we as a race of
people in the world can learn to
avoid it at all costs absolutely
thank you holly thank you thank you both
and with that holly has
left the building and left us with an
incredible book with some incredible
accounts in it so
definitely check out that book a lot of
horror in that book
yeah a lot of horror in the world yeah
yeah it's bad hell like like she'll
describe
each detail and it goes along with kind
of what we've been saying a lot where
it's like yeah when you just
individualize one thing and see their
story it's like oh man it really opens
up this
perspective of like man this is bad yep
yeah and by the way this is 430
something page book
you know and i probably read 20 pages
something like that
so it's an awesome book
and yeah check it out a lot of horror a
lot of horror in the book
a lot of horror in the world i kind of
feel like
we should do our best
to bring some good in the world
starting with our own lives yes trying
to live a good
life live a good life yeah start there
yeah kind of be appreciative too you
know oh yeah
i didn't bring it up holly just
you know um living on the floor of some
random
blown-out building she's getting after
it man
she's getting after it she doesn't she
she talks about it but it's not that's
what i
it's very humbly written story because
it's not about
her yeah yeah that's good it's not about
her
it's about the people and so with that
it's
yeah yeah very cool yeah that says kind
of a lot too about
an author don't make it about themselves
because you could
she could oh this could 100 this could
be a book
about her yeah 100 i went here and i did
this and i did that
it's not that that's not what the book
is i thought my life
is about to be over yeah in fact i had
to drag it out of her
i had to drag out of her where she came
from and how it started and how she got
there she just jumps right into it
and what you just said about i was here
and i was there
she'll be talking about it and i can
tell what she
means but a lot of people it's going to
she said
you know their explosion happened here
but you know what i'm i'm thinking okay
i know what's happening there
there's gunfire going on that's not she
just kind of
puts it under the rate under the radar
kind of her mo
is to be under the radar so
yeah you know so yeah
yeah we do have to be appreciative for
sure where like even at
like even if you're not involved
in the war in these places
even though i guess be appreciative of
that
yeah because like your day-to-day life
here
versus day-to-day life there even best
case scenarios bro it's different your
worst case your worst day here
is better than your best day there for
99 of the population
if not more oh yeah so yeah men
make the best of it's one of those deals
right anyway
all right so yes let's not let our lives
and capabilities go to waste in any way
let's try not to how about that
intention is a big deal you know it is
just knowing these things that's a
that's a huge
start you know like gi joe remember what
they'd say
knowing is half the battle did gi joe
actually say that i thought that was sun
tzu and twenty five thousand
twenty five hundred years ago no yeah
yes sir so probably gi joe yeah so you
got to keep these things in mind did you
work out today
if you're like oh wait did i work out
and you got to know this kind of stuff
and you got to know whether or not
you're working out tomorrow you see him
saying working out is
important definitely and yes i did work
out today yes sir you work out every day
right
seven days like that's that's the the
that's that's the jam yeah
i recently incorporated that into my
whole thing
usually i'd have a five day and then two
rest day situation two rest days yes sir
back to back
yes sir like usually the weekend because
my program goes five days at a time
like week by week and that's just how it
is convenient and
it is convenient but it had that was it
even before even before i was like well
i need rest days or nothing like that or
had less
one had less going on that's what i'm
saying so that was the the structured
program but
i found that if you sort of spread it
out a little bit more and i try to go
hard too on every single day
like hard at least one thing hard you
know some people they'll be like oh yeah
seven days but like this one or two days
like it's like a mobility day or
whatever well i might have
depending on how i feel i can i can tell
when i've beat myself
down to where i need a quote mobility
data for sure
oh yeah i'll usually still try and break
a sweat yeah like just at a minimum just
you know at a minute i'm going to break
a sweat yeah see and that
and you know there's uh there's a bunch
of different effective
philosophies in working out and working
on programs so like i get i'm not saying
oh you're
not going to be as good as mine i'm not
saying that at all but
i found and currently what i'm currently
on is the to
um do something hard like hard
where your body has to be like hey we
got to recover from
this whether it be like a one small body
part situation even like a metcon
situation like that just
at least one thing i like that on these
kind of one-off days
a normal workout day is hard is it's
going to be a hard one
oh you're saying on the easier day
you're still going to do one thing hard
hard yet
i like it i actually do a very similar
version of that
not consciously but unconsciously yeah
so let's say i'm going a little bit
let's say i'm not going super hard
metcon style
but i'm going to probably go heavy or if
i'm going heavy or if i'm
not really like feeling the metcon i'll
go heavy somewhere yeah
so i guess we're kind of in the same
boat there yeah it keeps your body there
trying to you know
trying to adapt adapt and get you know
kind of re
uh rebuild itself as the new and
improved version
anyway so hopefully we can kind of take
this philosophy and apply it to our
whole life hopefully
i'm saying but here's here's the thing
keep in mind we might need some
supplementation from time to time
you don't get you don't get
nine hours of sleep every single night
you know you don't you don't
max maximally nine hours because
is that it hey everybody's different so
you don't you don't recover
max you don't maximize your recovery
every single day
okay once well you need some
supplementation for sure you need
supplementation
in fact you got a little supplementation
routine boom you're gonna be on the
track
even quicker faster more effectively
no worries jocko has some
supplementation choco fuel so here it is
you need protein supplementation
got milk tastes like a dessert by the
way i've been on that train for
about almost a month now
i forgot i forgot the joy the glory um
so actually we're going to rewind just a
little bit so all this stuff you can be
on a subscription
yeah we mentioned it before but the
subscription you will
not have to pay shipping right you will
not have to remember to take these
less fun ones to take and i mean less
fun like they're
like anti-fun i'm just saying the
difference between taking a milkshake
drinking a milkshake
and taking joint warfare or super cruel
oil
like one has like a pleasurable
experience one is kind of like okay you
just sort of do it one's prolonged
pleasure when you don't have joint pain
yeah but that's the delayed that's the
deal gratification
i'm just saying if you forget like it's
a little bit more
can be more of a thing anyway track you
got a subscription you don't have to
even think about that kind of stuff also
do you get a
like a discount or something you get a
discount right yep little ten percent
discount
boom so if you subscribe yeah yeah and
free shipping so you combine those two
things together
we're in a good spot oh yeah so it's
kind of a win-win
yeah it's a no-brainer if you're like if
you're taking
it consistently which you should be
trust me the difference between even
that taking it not taking it
consistently night and day man so if
you're doing it
it's a win-win-win really triple win
triple win comment so
jacofuel.com you can get your
supplementation there which you
apparently do need
you do need and if you subscribe to it
you get shipping free and you get 10 off
which is cool
you can also get the drinks the go
drinks at wawa you can get all the
supplements at vitamin shop
so there you go or jockofield.com yep do
what you want to do
do what you do if you see something if
you like something you get something get
something
also at origenmaine.com
jeans geez all american made by the way
all american made yeah all meaning
all of them and all meaning the entire
product itself
is all american made do you can you
and i don't expect you to answer this
question but i wonder if you can find
something that's not american made in
the whole chain like if you go to one of
the looms that they got could you find
like a set of screws that are used in
there
you'll be like hey those are made in you
know somewhere else you are going to be
hard-pressed to find something in your
genes that is not
100 percent american
crazy in fact the jeans i can tell you
there's nothing that's not american-made
the clothing 100 american-made i mean
and not only is it 100 american-made
we know where it came from we know where
the
the hide is that we're getting the
leather from
we know where that is yeah it goes deep
so
yeah american-made bunch of awesome
stuff by a bunch of all made by a bunch
of awesome people
in farmington maine yep sorry
originusa.com sorry i said origin maine
i'm sure you can still go to origin you
can't let's face it
originusa.com a little bit stronger
we'll say
stronger yes not that maine's not strong
but look
who would you rather fight a war against
maine or america
you know what i'm saying including maine
yeah which includes maine right so i
think we'll go
we'll go with origin usa yes sir i agree
so yes
also jocko has a store as well
dracostore.com
this is where you can get your
discipline equals freedom shirts and
hats and hoodies
good all kinds of cool stuff on there
you get the shirt i'm wearing right now
yeah you can get the jacket that you're
wearing is that called a jacket
lightweight hoodie you can get a
lightweight hoodie that echo charles is
wearing right now
yeah why it's lightweight hoodie weather
you're over here taking on and off your
hoodie which i dig
it's just off currently it is because
i'm warm enough
you showed you showed up with it on you
see what i'm saying
cool outside i showed up with mine on
fine came in here
fine you see i'm saying though so all
i'm going to tell you is that in the
middle of the bell curve
you're good if we go outside the bell
curve in either direction you're out of
here out of luck
so if it gets a little colder you're
screwed and if it gets more hot
you're screwed yeah that's true so i
guess it looks like i'm right
i i like the aesthetic value that this
lightweight
okay so you like the look some of us
some of us like this kind of stuff some
of us are just over here trying to win
nonetheless worried about how we look
nonetheless
these things are available for those of
us who appreciate it
speaking of appreciation if you can
appreciate let's say one-off
designs or concepts we call them layers
from time to time
on our apparel that we choose to wear
because
it looks good and feels good we have a
little subscription situation as well
so it's the shirt locker we've uh landed
on that name
with the help of jocko's creativity no
no that was not my creativity that was a
suggestion from the trooper yep
i got your name the shirt locker because
the name which i will not mention
because i don't want to hear it yes sir
that echo charles
lack of creativity yes sir okay got us
too
we'll will that's the name that will not
be spoken shall not be spoken okay
because now we got something good the
shirt locker
locker so that is a monthly thing you
get a new a new design
they're cool they're they're there's
some layers
there's a attention and focus on
the layers so if you listen you know and
you're gonna
understand this
it kind of is yes sir but yes yeah check
that out
and if that seems cool hey that might
that one might be for you as well
jugglestore.com that's where you can get
those
subscribe to the podcast leave a review
if you want to
we also got other podcasts we got the
jocko unraveling podcast
which daryl cooper is in the house we
should be rolling out with some of those
grounded podcasts
again work in it
and the warrior kid podcast working it i
have
some time coming up so we should get
some of those done you can also join us
at the jocko underground dot com
jocko underground.com we have
alternative podcasts with some
amplifying information
some other subject matter some behind
the scenes we've got some q a that we're
working on where you can
send in your audio voice video thing and
we'll put all that together
also the underground what i kind of
notice when i listen to them and stuff
these are like i mean i think it all
even the jock podcast of course like
makes your brain like think and work and
stuff but
it's like i find myself like doing
little brain
it's like exercise for your brain almost
you know you start to think about stuff
like oh wait do i do that
oh wait does that apply to me yeah i
would tell you that the subject matter
in the jocko underground podcasts are
based on
me going through daily life and
recognizing the patterns and the
maneuvers
and the thoughts and the and the
curiosity
and hey wait why do i why did that
happen why do we do that
and sometimes it doesn't fit into a
jocko podcast because it's some
something about psychology or something
about negotiating whatever
yeah and so but it's very important and
does it
it's like a venn diagram is there some
part of it that's leadership yes there
is
some hundred that's the history yes
there's some psychology some social it's
all mixed in there but what it's what it
is it's all subject matter
that will help you helps me it helps me
but it's me digging into and revealing
why these things are happening why am i
doing these things sometimes my
instincts are good
sometimes they're not good but either
way i'm gonna learn from it
and it's just the approach that i take
in life to try and
figure something out because like jiu
jitsu you know when you train jujitsu
and someone goes oh
put your arm here and you're like okay
but then the next day you don't really
remember that but if someone says put
your put your arm here and here's why
you do it
and you start to understand the concept
so
i think that's a big part of the jocko
underground podcast is what's the
concept behind what's happening here
what makes it like jiu-jitsu obviously a
great analogy where like
there's certain things in jiu-jitsu and
subsequently
in life or your day-to-day whatever that
certain things are not intuitive in fact
they're
counter counter into like you know just
to turn your back right and
like a full like there's so many reasons
in regular life to like turn your back
that's the best move it feels like it
from moment to moment like if someone's
mounted on you like turning your back
if you never trained you did too it's
weird basically i want to get away how
do you get away turn
your back and run away yeah right you
can't run anymore
yeah like if you're mounting you try to
stand up the most powerful way you can
stand up is to turn over and stand up
with him on your back
you can't do a sit-up with someone
correct you know so it's like there's
all these intuitive things that are
incorrect that is going to make you lose
and then in life it's the same thing
with
like a lot of those whether it be the
cognitive biases or whatever it's kind
of the same thing and everything
yeah it's real interesting how you kind
of explore them and you're like oh man
you shoot
and then then you know what to do and
what not to do
so that's the jockowunderground.com if
you want to if you want to come and
check that out look it's
it's also us our way of having a
contingency plan
in case things get wild in case
there's a bunch of things that could
happen look we could get
censored for something that some subject
matter that we cover
we could get people could start to say
okay well now you're gonna
we're gonna put our inject
advertisements into your podcast
we don't want that we we just want to
have a
long advertisement at the end that echo
talks for 48 minutes on
but we don't want that so that's what
we're doing we don't we don't want to be
held hostage by a platform or held
hostage by
sponsors and so eight dollars and
eighteen cents a month if you want you
can
you can join the jocko underground dot
com
and and if you can't afford that look
we're not
uh we're not trying to be elite
so if you can't afford it no factor
email assistance
jockonunderground.com and we will take
care of you
it's true we also have a youtube channel
where you can check out
echo charles's legit videos
where i on the good ones i'm the
assistant director on the bad ones
he kind of goes solo so you can check
those out lots of explosions
we have an album with tracks called
psychological warfare
you can listen to that if you have a
momentary
just a just a just a temptation that you
need to overcome it's okay
hit play psychological warfare all on
your mp3
platforms flip side canvas
dakota meyer flipsidecanvas.com cool
stuff to hang on your wall
we have a bunch of books only cry for
the living by holly mckay there you go
check that one out final spin a novel
written
by me we don't even know if it's a novel
i don't know if it's a novel i don't
know if it's a poem i don't know if it's
just i don't know what it is
but we'll see i've been getting warnings
people are going to critique you i'm
like that warning what are they going to
say to me
your book sucks cool thank you
carry on good critique thanks leadership
strategy and tactics field manual the
code the evaluations protocols displace
freedom fan
field manual warrior kid one two three
and four
get those for any kids that you know
mike in the dragons get those with the
little kids that you know
about face by hackworth extreme
ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership
echelon front is my leadership
consultancy we solve problems through
leadership if you
need help with leadership in your
organization go to ashlandfront.com
we have ef online which is leadership
training online which means you can get
it for everybody that you know
everyone inside your organization and
whatever problems you're having inside
your organization the problems get
solved through leadership as i just said
well there's nothing better than getting
everyone on your team
aligned around the same principles of
leadership it's
it's insane to think you would even try
and run an organization
without having everyone aligned around
the same principles of leadership so go
to efonline.com
and start taking some courses go through
the program
come and do q and a's
we have a live gig that we do we're
doing three of them this year go to
extreme ownership.com if you want to
come to those
ef overwatch if you need people inside
your company
to help you with your leadership that
you want to hire go to eforewatch.com
and if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their family families you want to help
gold star families check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to
americasmightywarriors.org
and if you want to continue this
conversation we're on the interwebs
once again holly is on twitter and on
instagram
holly s mckay it's h-o-l-l-i-e-s
mckay m-c-k-a-y
and she's on facebook holly mckay and
she also has
holly mckay.com and of course
echo and i are also on the interwebs on
twitter on
instagram which echo only refers to as
the graham
and facebook echoes that aquacharles and
i am matt jockle willing thanks once
again to
holly mckay for
taking risk for showing courage and for
capturing these stories to share with
all of us
and thanks to all the military personnel
out there all over the world
who stand and face evil like isis
every day thank you for keeping that
evil at bay and right here at home
all the police and law enforcement
firefighters and paramedics and emts and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and border patrol and secret service and
all first responders
thank you for keeping us safe on the
home front
and everyone else out there
you heard it today there is a lot of
evil in the world
it's everywhere and it's
up to all of us to fight against it
that doesn't mean you you have to pick
up a gun doesn't mean you have to pick
up a weapon doesn't mean you have to go
overseas
but you have to fight it
and we have to make sure we keep it at
bay
by making sure we never forget that it's
there
and then what we need to do is go out
every day and do good
and bring light into the world
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out